Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Today we are insulted. Our blood brothers are at the mercy of their cruel abusers without any means of defending themselves. I am speaking of Czechoslovakia. Among the suppressed minorities in this state are three and a half million Germans. These Germans are God's creatures. The Almighty did not create them so that the reign over these three and a half million,
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告干扰版、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社团，请登录 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。今天我们受到了侮辱。我们的血肉同胞在残忍的虐待者面前任人宰割，毫无自卫能力。我所说的就是捷克斯洛伐克。在这个国家受压迫的少数群体中，有三百五十万德国人。这些德国人是上帝的子民。全能的上帝创造他们，不是为了让别人统治这三百五十万人，
keep them in tutelage, and far less did he create them for ravage and torture. The misery of the Sudeten Germans defies description. They are being oppressed and humiliated in an unprecedented fashion. There must be an end to the injustice inflicted upon these people. The Reich will no longer stand for any further oppression and persecutions of these three and a half million Germans. It is the duty of all of us to never again bow our heads to any alien will. To this, let us pledge ourselves. So help us God. So that Dominic was very much not a friend of the show Adolf Hitler. and he was speaking to the Nazi Party Congress in Nuremberg on the 12th of September 1938 about Czechoslovakia, as he frames it. And it's the beginning of the year. We're
让他们处于受监护的地位，更不是为了让他们遭受蹂躏和折磨。苏台德德国人的悲惨处境难以言表。他们正遭受着空前绝后的压迫和羞辱。加诸这些人身上的不公正必须结束。德意志帝国绝不会再容忍对这三百五十万德国人的任何进一步压迫和迫害。我们所有人的责任，就是永不向任何外来意志低头。为此，让我们立下誓言。愿上帝保佑我们。因此，多米尼克非常不喜欢本节目的嘉宾阿道夫·希特勒。他当时正在纽伦堡发表讲话，那是1938年9月12日的纳粹党代表大会上，内容是关于他所构建的捷克斯洛伐克。现在是一年初。我们
into 2025 now. And on the rest of history, if it's the new year, it must be Nazis. You're not wrong there, Tom. That was a very spirited performance. You didn't do an accent, which is probably best. I wanted to evoke the sense of Hitler through the power of my acting and my oratory. So I hope people got that sense. If you do get cancelled for that reading, it's good to bow out in a very spirited performance. I also hope that people who may be watching this on YouTube will enjoy the hand gestures, which I thought were very Hitlerian.
已经进入2025年了。而在《历史的其余部分》里，既然是新年，那就一定少不了纳粹。汤姆，你这话倒也没错。那是一场充满激情的表演。你没有模仿口音，这大概是最好的选择。我想通过我的演技和演讲力量来唤起人们对希特勒的感觉。所以我希望大家能感受到这一点。如果你真的因为那段朗读而被封杀，能在这样一场充满激情的表演中谢幕也算不错。我也希望那些在YouTube上观看这个视频的人会喜欢这些手势，我觉得这些手势非常具有希特勒的风格。
They were very Hitlerian, yeah. And actually the funny thing is those are your usual hand gestures. It is. It is. That's actually how you speak off camera. So actually I find it quite easy. Exactly. So let's give people a bit of context.
确实非常具有希特勒的风格，是的。事实上，有趣的是，那些正是你平时常用的手势。没错。确实如此。这其实就是你离开镜头时的说话方式。所以实际上我发现这相当容易。完全正确。那么，让我们为听众提供一些背景信息吧。
What Hitler is doing there obviously is he's on the face of it, defending the interests of the German speaking minority in Western Czechoslovakia. People who he says have been ravaged and tortured by their Czech or Czechoslovakian overlords. Of course, what he's really doing is preparing the ground for the invasion and dismemberment of Czechoslovakia, which he sees as a crucial step towards the creation of a new German dominion in central and Eastern Europe. And Tom, as you said, we always like to welcome the new year with a series about the Nazis. With a Third Reich.
希特勒在那里显然所做的是，表面上看，他是在捍卫捷克斯洛伐克西部德语少数群体的利益。这些人被他称之为遭到捷克或捷克斯洛伐克统治者蹂躏和折磨。当然，他真正要做的是为入侵和肢解捷克斯洛伐克做铺平道路，他认为这是在欧洲中东部建立新的德意志统治的关键一步。汤姆，正如你所说，我们总是喜欢用一个关于纳粹的系列来迎接新年。用第三帝国。
With a Third Reich. So we've done two series in the last couple of years. The first one was about the Nazis rise to power in the 1920s up to 1933, and the second one was about the Nazis in power in the course of the 30s. And this one really will lead us up to the outbreak of the Second World War and the fall of Poland. And this week, we're going to be focusing on one of the most discussed, most controversial, most, I guess, genuinely infamous diplomatic episodes in history, which is the Munich Agreement of October 1938. I mean, I would say it's possibly the incident from history that has had the greatest influence on the way people, certainly people in the West have approached international affairs
用第三帝国。所以我们在过去几年里做过两个系列。第一个系列是关于20年代到1933年纳粹的崛起，第二个系列是关于30年代掌权时期的纳粹。而这个系列将真正把我们带到第二次世界大战的爆发和波兰的沦陷。本周，我们将聚焦于历史上讨论最多、最具争议、我猜也是真正声名狼藉的外交事件之一，即1938年10月的《慕尼黑协定》。我的意思是，我会说这可能是历史上对人们（尤其是西方人）处理国际事务的方式产生最大影响的事件，
since the war. I mean, basically it kind of lies behind everything from the Suez crisis to the invasion of Iraq. It absolutely does. We don't want to be Neville Chamberlain. We want to face down dictators. Yeah. The Munich analogy is probably the most well- well worn analogy, as you say, in all international relations. And actually, I think it's a crisis that's generally a bit misunderstood. And that the nuances of it are more surprising and more interesting than people think. And maybe the lessons that people draw are not necessarily always the right ones. So I think
自战争以来。我的意思是，基本上它几乎是苏伊士运河危机到伊拉克战争背后的一切根源。确实如此。我们不想成为内维尔·张伯伦。我们要直面独裁者。是的。正如你所说，慕尼黑类比可能是所有国际关系中最陈词滥调、最常被提及的类比。实际上，我认为这是一个普遍被有些误解的危机，其细微差别比人们想象的更令人惊讶、更有趣，而且人们得出的教训也未必总是正确的。所以我认为
generally when people use the Munich analogy, they're using it merely as a political tool. As a justification to go to war. Justification for something they wanted to do anyway. Of course that's what politicians always do, isn't it? So let's dig into this in proper detail. And we'll start by, I think, by reminding ourselves how absolutely central the idea of war is to the whole Nazi project. So obviously the first point, the foundational point is that Nazism is driven above all by
通常当人们使用慕尼黑类比时，他们只是把它当作一种政治工具。作为发动战争的借口。作为他们无论如何都想做的事情的借口。政客们总是这样，不是吗？让我们深入探讨一下这个问题的具体细节。我想我们首先要提醒自己，战争的概念对于整个纳粹计划是多么的核心。所以显而易见的第一点，也是最基础的一点是，纳粹主义最主要是由
the shattering experience of the Great War and by the desire to put that right. So as Ian Kershaw says, Richard Evans, all the great historians of Nazism and of Hitler, the single thing that drives it more than anything else is a sense of humiliation and a thirst for revenge after 1918. And actually you don't need to be a Nazi to have that. So loads of people in Germany have that. Any conceivable nationalistic German leader in the 1930s or 1940s would probably have wanted to fight a war. So the Nazis come to power kind of in alliance with the conservative militaristic elites who had been, well had been the elites, you know, since the time
第一次世界大战那粉碎性的经历以及纠正这一局面的渴望所驱动的。正如伊恩·克肖、理查德·埃文斯以及所有研究纳粹主义和希特勒的伟大历史学家所说的那样，推动这一切的最主要动力是一种耻辱感，以及在1918年之后对复仇的渴望。实际上，你不需要成为一个纳粹分子才能有这种感觉。德国有大量的人都有这种想法。在20世纪30年代或40年代，任何可想而知的民族主义德国领导人都可能会想打一场战争。所以纳粹掌权某种程度上是与保守的军国主义精英结盟，这些精英在——嗯，一直是精英，你知道，自凯撒时代
of the Kaiser and before. And in 1938, are they still, they're still on the scene, right? I mean, they've kind of been slightly sidelined, but they're still part of the makeup of the state. Yeah, absolutely they are. And obviously in the army, there are lots of people in the army who've been there for years. And Hitler's ambitions are absolutely, as they see it,
及之前以来。而在1938年，他们还在吗？他们依然在场，对吧？我的意思是，他们多少被边缘化了一点，但他们仍然是国家体制构成的一部分。是的，他们绝对在。而且显然在军队里，有很多人已经在军队里呆了很多年。正如他们所看到的，希特勒的雄心完全
in tune with their own longstanding ambitions that they've had since the day they were defeated in 1918, which is let's make Germany great again. Let's get our territory back. Let's expand our borders, all of that. Right. But make Germany great again and get our borders back, but not necessarily as you go into other countries that don't contain Germans and conquer them as well. And if Czechoslovakia contains a minority of Germans, then the majority
与他们自1918年战败之日起就拥有的长期雄心不谋而合，那就是让我们再次伟大。收复我们的领土。扩大我们的边界，诸如此类。没错，但是让德国再次伟大并收复我们的边界，却不一定非要去征服那些不包含德国人的其他国家。如果捷克斯洛伐克包含少数德国人，那么多数人
are Czech or Slovaks. And so that makes it slightly different, doesn't it? Yeah, who've never been part of Germany. Exactly right. So I think the point worth making is that Hitler, of course, is not an ordinary nationalistic politician. He's not like a lot of these other people. So he has a very, very distinctive worldview, which we discussed a great length in the very first series we did. And at the centre of it is this idea of racial struggle that comes from the social Darwinist ideas of the 1880s and 1890s. You know, you open the pages of Mein Kampf, it's all full of this stuff
就是捷克人或斯洛伐克人。这就让情况稍微有些不同了，对吧？是的，他们从来都不是德国的一部分。完全正确。所以我想值得指出的一点是，希特勒当然不是一个普通的民族主义政治家。他不像许多其他人那样。因此他有着非常非常独特的世界观，我们在我们制作的第一个系列中对此进行了深入探讨。而它的核心是这种种族斗争的思想，它源自1880年代和1890年代的社会达尔文主义思想。你知道，你翻开《我的奋斗》，里面到处都是这些东西，
about a coming race war, the struggle for the the future of the planet. I mean, here's a random quotation, he who would live must fight. He who does not wish to fight in this world where permanent struggle is the law of life does not have the right to exist. Other European politicians do not talk like this in the 1920s and 1930s. This is distinctive. You have to fight or you will be destroyed yourself. Exactly. So I think it's fair to say that from the moment Hitler is propelled into office by those conservative elites in January 1933, absolutely everything is about preparing Germany for war. War is not an accident. War is the end goal. Richard Evans is brilliant on this in his book
关于即将到来的种族战争，关于争夺地球未来的斗争。我的意思是，这里有一句随机的引言：“欲生存者必战斗；在这个永久斗争即为生活规律的世界里，不愿战斗者没有生存的权利。”20世纪20年代和30年代的其他欧洲政治家不会这样说话。这是独一无二的。你必须战斗，否则你就会被消灭。完全正确。因此，我认为可以公平地说，从希特勒在1933年1月被那些保守精英推上权力宝座的那一刻起，绝对一切都是为了让德国为战争做准备。战争不是偶然。战争是最终目标。理查德·埃文斯在他关于纳粹掌权的书里对此有精彩的论述，他谈到希特勒所做的一切都是为了让德国和权力
about the Nazis and power, about how everything that Hitler does is designed to make Germany and power about how everything that Hitler does is designed to make Germany racially fit for conflict. So that's everything from popular culture, from films and whatnot, all the way down to children's textbooks. By hammering this point home, life is about struggle, the fittest will survive, you have to be hard, you have to be ruthless. There's a lot of P.E. isn't there? There's an awful lot of P.E.
在种族上适合冲突。所以从流行文化、电影之类的一直到儿童教科书，一切都是为了灌输这个核心观点：生活就是斗争，适者生存，你必须坚强，你必须冷酷无情。里面有很多体育课，不是吗？有非常多的体育课。
But there's a sort of a lot, there's a moral re-education. You did a brilliant episode in our last series about the Nazis, about this kind of attempt to morally re-educate people, to brainwash people, I guess, so that they become harder than hard. You know, the most ruthless people on the face of the planet. Spartans. Spartans, exactly. Exactly.
但这是一种道德重塑。你在我们关于纳粹的上一个系列中做了一集精彩的节目，讲的是这种试图在道德上重塑人们、给人们洗脑的尝试，我猜是为了让他们变得比钢铁还硬。你知道，地球上面对最冷酷无情的人。斯巴达人。斯巴达人，完全正确。完全正确。
So in pursuit of his goal, Hitler has been helped by three things. First of all, you've already mentioned it, he's had the support of the army and the conservative establishment because they're delighted by this. This is what they always wanted. Secondly, he benefits from the fact that internationally, the Germans do actually have genuine sympathy. There are loads of people in Britain and France who for completely understandable reasons, you may not agree with them now, but lots of people, you can understand why they thought it, people feel guilty about the Great War and the way that it ended. They
因此，为了追求他的目标，希特勒得到了三件事的帮助。首先，正如你已经提到的，他得到了军队和保守建制派的支持，因为他们对此感到高兴。这正是他们一直想要的。其次，他受益于这样一个事实：在国际上，德国人实际上赢得了真正的同情。英国和法国有大量的人，出于完全可以理解的原因——你现在可能不同意他们的看法，但很多人，你可以理解他们为什么会这么想——人们对第一次世界大战以及它的结束方式感到内疚。他们
think it was a terrible struggle, slaughter. Germany did lose a lot of territory. It did lose a lot of German speakers. Who wouldn't be a bit upset about that? Punic peace. Yeah. Why shouldn't Germany have a proper army? Why shouldn't the Germans be treated with dignity and respect? So there are lots of people who think that. And then the third thing is because of the Great Depression, Britain and France in particular
认为那是一场可怕的、血腥的斗争。德国确实失去了很多领土。它确实失去很多讲德语的人。谁会对这种事不感到有点难过呢？迦太基式的和平。是的。为什么德国不能拥有一支像样的军队？为什么德国人不能受到尊严和尊重的对待？所以有很多人是这么想的。然后第三件事是，由于大萧条，英国和法国特别是
are fixated on their own internal problems. And they don't want to spend a lot of money on guns. They want to spend a lot of money on soup kitchens. So quite familiar. Yeah. Yes, exactly. Very familiar. So all of this meant that Hitler's foreign policy up to 1938 had actually been, if you're a conservative or nationalistic German, it's a succession of foreign policy, stunning achievements.
陷入了各自的内部问题中无法自拔。他们不想在武器上花很多钱。他们想在救济厨房上花很多钱。所以这相当熟悉。是的。没错，非常熟悉。所有这一切意味着，如果从保守或民族主义的德国人的角度来看，希特勒到1938年为止的外交政策实际上是一连串惊人的外交政策成就。
It takes them out to the League of Nations, massive rearmament, goes back into the Rhineland, which we did an episode about that, alliances with Italy and Japan, intervenes in the Spanish Civil War, and then most spectacularly annexes Austria in March 1938. So it takes a big German speaking country and brings it his homeland and brings it into the Reich. And at this point, nobody says at this point, well, these are very outlandish goals and clearly he's the man who wants to take over the world. I mean, well, these are very outlandish goals and clearly he's the man who wants to take over the world. I mean, well, a few people do, Churchill or whoever, but in Germany, people say this is
他让德国退出国联，大规模重新武装，重返莱茵兰（我们为此做过一期节目），与意大利和日内瓦（原文如此，实为日本）结盟，干预西班牙内战，然后最轰动的是在1938年3月吞并了奥地利。所以他拿下一个讲德语的大国，将其纳入他的祖国并带入帝国。而此时，没有人说——此时，这些都是极其离谱的目标，显然他是一个想征服世界的人。我的意思是，好吧，少数人会这么说，比如丘吉尔之流，但在德国，人们会说这
actually completely reasonable. This is like he's going down the wish list of things that any patriotic German would want to see. We would want to have our troops in the Rhineland. We would want to bring Austria. What's wrong with that? Yeah, what's wrong with that? National self-determination, because that's the Hitler's genius, we would want to bring Austria. What's wrong with that? National self-determination,
实际上完全合情合理。这就像他在顺着任何一个爱国德国人希望看到的愿望清单往下走。我们希望我们的军队驻扎在莱茵兰。我们希望把奥地利并入。这有什么错？是的，这有什么错？民族自决，因为那是希特勒的天才之处——我们希望把奥地利并入。这有什么错？民族自决，
because that's the Hitler's genius, isn't it? Is that the League of Nations, which has been set up after the First World War, it's all about national self-determination. It's the progressive thing to be in favour of. So why shouldn't Germans have self-determination like everyone else? That's exactly what he's playing on. And, you know, if you have a city or a country with loads of German speakers who want to be part of Germany, the Woodrow Wilson Versailles Treaty League of Nations principle is you let them choose. You give them the freedom to choose. Absolutely.
因为那是希特勒的天才之处，不是吗？那就是在第一次世界大战后建立的国际联盟，全都是关于民族自决的。这是支持进步的事业。那么为什么德国人不能像其他人一样拥有自决权呢？这正是他所利用的。而且，你知道，如果你有一个城市或一个国家，里面有大量想成为德国一部分的讲德语的人，那么伍德罗·威尔逊、凡尔赛条约、国联的原则就是让他们自己选择。给他们选择的自由。绝对是这样。
And he has judged the whole thing perfectly. As Ian Kershaw says in his brilliant biography, he had been bold, but not reckless, his timing had been excellent. The combination of bluff and blackmail effective. His manipulation of propaganda to back his coups masterly. That sounds like Kershaw is an admirer of Hitler, which he absolutely isn't. But he's played his cards really, really cleverly. And the result every time has been a massive propaganda boost. So you have these wonderful sources on public opinion in Germany, which are the reports of social democratic party, SPD agents to their leaders in exile. And they say, look, he's really popular whenever he does this.
而且他把这一切拿捏得完美无缺。正如伊恩·克肖在他那本精彩的传记中所说，他大胆但并不鲁莽，他的时机把握得极好。虚张声势与勒索的结合非常有效。他为政变造势的宣传操纵堪称大师级。这听起来好像克肖是希特勒的崇拜者，而他绝对不是。但他把牌打得非常非常聪明。而每次的结果都是宣传上的一次巨大提振。所以你拥有这些关于德国公众舆论的绝佳一手资料，那就是社会民主党（SPD）特工给他们在流亡中的领导人的报告。报告说，看，每当他这么做时，他真的很受欢迎。
His popularity will often flag and then I'll have a foreign policy achievement. And even people who don't really like him will say, oh, Hitler, you know, he's brilliant. Getting the Austrians back, that was fantastic. All of this kind of thing. Yeah. So it may not be running, making the trains run on time necessarily, but he does get chunks of the Austro-Hungarian empire that had never belonged to Germany before. You know, we've now got them.
他的受欢迎程度有时会下滑，然后我就会取得一项外交政策上的成就。甚至那些并不真正喜欢他的人也会说：“哦，希特勒，你知道的，他太棒了。把奥地利夺回来，那太棒了。”诸如此类的话。是的。所以这可能不一定是在让火车准点运行，但他确实拿下了奥匈帝国从未属于德国的部分。你知道，我们现在把它们弄到手了。
Hooray. Exactly. Hitler himself, by the way, has, by this point, 1938, he has completely drunk the Kool-Aid, so he, as Kershaw says, he began thinking that he was merely going to be John the Baptist to some other nationalistic leader. He was the drummer in his own terminology. But by this point, he really believes, I mean, he refers to it again and again in his speeches. He says, you know, I've been chosen by Providence. Fate has appointed me to bring the Germans to greatness. So nobody believes in the Fuhrer cult more
万岁。完全正确。顺便说一句，希特勒本人到这个时候（1938年）已经彻底迷失在自己的狂热中了，所以正如克肖所说，他开始认为自己只不过是某个其他民族主义领袖的施洗约翰。用他自己的术语来说，他只是个鼓手。但到了这个时候，他真的相信——我的意思是他在演讲中一次又一次地提到这一点。他说，你知道的，我被上天选中了。命运指派我带领德国走向伟大。所以没有人比希特勒本人更相信
than Hitler himself. And by this point, he's going to be turning 50 next year in 1939, he feels a tremendous sense of urgency. He feels that weight of history on his shoulders as it were. Well, but I mean, it's kind of more supernatural than that, isn't it? He feels appointed by some Inchoate spirit to guide his nation to glory. He totally does. And he believes that literally. Yes, he does. I mean, it's not just a kind of abstract spirit. He feels ordained by some supernatural power.
元首崇拜了。而且到这个时候，他明年（1939年）就要50岁了，他感到了一种极大的紧迫感。他仿佛感到历史的重任压在自己的肩上。好吧，但我的意思是，这比那更超自然一些，不是吗？他觉得自己被某种模糊的精神所指定，来引领他的国家走向辉煌。他完全是这么想的。他是字面意义上这么相信的。是的，他确实如此。我的意思是，这不仅仅是一种抽象的精神。他觉得自己被某种超自然力量按立了。
Yeah. It's like he's a kind of Hegelian character who incarnates the spirit of history and science and he's been appointed. Yeah, exactly that. However, what's nagging at him is that both his parents died young and he himself is a horrendous hypochondriac. Well he's drinking gun cleaning oil, isn't he? He is. We talked about that in the previous episode and I think we both agreed that although we don't have medical backgrounds, we didn't feel this was the wisest thing for him to be drinking.
是的。这就像他是一个体现了历史与科学精神的黑格尔式人物，并且他被指定了。是的，完全是这样。然而，一直折磨着他的是，他的父母都很年轻就去世了，而他本人又是一个极其严重的疑病症患者。好吧，他在喝擦枪油，不是吗？他是的。我们在上一集里谈过这个，我想我们俩都同意，虽然我们没有医学背景，但我们不觉得这是他当时最明智的饮品选择。
No, he's drinking this trench medicine, which is going clean the oil. And basically this gives him horrendous stomach problems. And to deal with this, his doctor who's called Dr Morel has given him this cocktail of kind of vitamins and amphetamines and stuff that he is taking. So basically it's fair to say Hitler is, he's a bit of a crank. I bet we can go on the record here. Well, I hope that people sense the presence of amphetamines in that performance I gave at the start of the show. I almost certainly they did. So he's got a kind of personal sense of urgency. He thinks
不，他喝的是这种战壕里的药，也就是擦枪油。基本上这给他带来了可怕的胃部问题。为了解决这个问题，他的医生莫雷尔医生给了他这种由维生素和苯丙胺等混合而成的鸡尾酒，他在服用。所以基本上可以公平地说，希特勒是个怪人。我敢在这里留下记录。好吧，我希望人们能从我演出节目开始时那种表演中感受到苯丙胺的存在。他们几乎百分之百感受到了。所以他有一种个人的紧迫感。他认为
he might drop dead at any moment. Secondly, the kind of wheels are beginning to come off the German economy. The German economy has been built on massive arms spending and because of that they are always running out of, remember we talked about this bit in the last series, they're always running out of fats of various kinds. Butter, lard, I don't know, oil. They're always running out of these things. There's always massive kind of consumer shortages and basically by 1938 the economy is very short of raw materials and cheap labour. And Goering, who's in charge of all this, keeps saying like the wheels are going to fall off at any minute.
自己随时可能会一命呜呼。其次，德国经济的车轮开始脱落。德国经济是建立在大规模军费开支之上的，正因为如此，他们总是缺少——还记得我们在上一系列中讨论过这个部分吗？——他们总是缺少各种各样的脂肪。黄油、猪油，我不知道，还有油。他们总是缺少这些东西。总是出现大规模的消费品短缺，基本上到1938年，经济非常缺乏原材料和廉价劳动力。主管这一切的戈林一直说，经济的车轮随时都会脱落。
And foreign currency as well has gone, hasn't it? Yeah. And aren't there international boycotts, which the Nazi high command can then blame on international juries? Exactly. Exactly. Right. Yeah. They've gone for an autarchy. So they've slightly tried to sort of go for sealing themselves off in the world economy and this huge drive for arms spending. But basically this is unsustainable and this is going to collapse in the next couple of years.
外汇也枯竭了，不是吗？是的。而且难道没有国际抵制吗？纳粹高级指挥部随后可以把这归咎于国际犹太人？完全正确。完全正确。是的。他们走上了自给自足的道路。所以他们稍微试图在世界经济中将自己封闭起来，并大力推行军费开支。但基本上这是不可持续的，这将在未来几年内崩溃。
Finally, they are conscious by 1938 that the Western Allies, Britain and France, are at last beginning to rearm. that the Western allies, Britain and France, are at last beginning to rearm. And so they, the window of opportunity as they see it is beginning to close. And at the end of 1937, Hitler told his bigwigs, look, we've probably got about seven years to do this. So I think we should be looking to fight a European war about 1943 to 1945. And the European war would include taking on Britain and France and attacking the Soviet Union.
最后，到1938年，他们意识到西方盟国（英国和法国）终于开始重新武装了。
So I mean, basically taking on everyone. I mean, what's it? What are his plans at that point? At this point, I think it's possible that in Hitler's dream scenario, he doesn't fight Britain. I think he probably thinks he'll always have to fight France, but he thinks the French can easily be beaten. Of course, he's not entirely wrong.
所以我的意思是，基本上要与所有人开战。我的意思是，他当时的计划是什么？在这一点上，我认为在希特勒的梦想剧本中，他有可能不与英国作战。我想他可能认为他总是不得不与法国作战，但他认为法国可以轻易被击败。当然，他并非完全错误。
So he'll leave Britain to its empire. Yes, because he's making off as we will discover in this series, he's making offers to Britain to stay out of the war until the very last possible minute. He's spending much more effort on Britain than he is on France. So some of his generals were always anxious about this. They'd liked the idea of fighting small Central European countries. They'd never liked the idea of fighting Britain and France. But by 1938, Hitler is being encouraged in this aim by a terrible man, another terrible man.
所以他会把英国留给它的帝国。是的，正如我们在这个系列中将发现的那样，他正在向英国提出建议，让其置身事分之外，直到最后一分钟。他在英国身上花费的精力比在法国身上还要多。因此，他的一些将军一直对此感到焦虑。他们喜欢与中欧小国作战的想法，但他们从来不喜欢与英法作战的想法。但到1938年，希特勒在这个目标上受到了一个可怕的人、另一个可怕的人的鼓励。
This guy is the ultimate kind of war hawk and he is the new foreign minister. And this is Joachim von Ribbentrop, who will be featuring a lot in this series. So if you see photographs of Ribbentrop, Ribbentrop looks kind of quite suave, doesn't he? And quite dapper, which was not his reputation in Britain where people said he was always wearing inappropriate trousers or something. Yes. And he's very rude to tailors in Britain. So he'll summon them to come and, you know, measure him and then he won't turn up. So his name is mud on Savile Row. Well, I mean, we take Savile Row very seriously, don't we, Tom?
这家伙是个彻头彻尾的好战分子，他就是新任外交部长。这就是约阿希姆·冯·里宾特洛甫，他将在这个系列中扮演重要角色。所以如果你看到里宾特洛甫的照片，里宾特洛甫看起来相当温文尔雅，不是吗？而且相当时髦，这在英国可不是他的名声，人们在英国说他总是穿着不合适的裤子什么的。是的。而且他对英国的裁缝非常粗鲁。所以他会召集他们来给他量尺寸，然后又不出现。因此他在萨维尔罗街（Savile Row）名誉扫地。好吧，我的意思是，我们对萨维尔罗街非常重视，对吧，汤姆？
We do. So that's very poor. And also the other thing, his name is Mud in the Church of England because he gives a Nazi salute in Durham Cathedral. Really? It has to be almost forcibly restrained. Yeah. Absolutely disgraces himself. So, Ruventrop had been ambassador to Britain.
我们是的。所以这真的很糟糕。还有另一件事，他在英格兰教会也名誉扫地，因为他在达勒姆大教堂行纳粹礼。真的吗？几乎得被人强行按住。是的。彻底丢尽了自己的脸。所以，里宾特洛甫曾担任过驻英大使。
He'd actually worked in Britain beforehand and he'd also worked in Canada before the war. So he speaks English, doesn't he? He speaks English. He'd won the Iron Cross in the Great War. So he was physically quite courageous, but then he'd worked in the drinks trade, hasn't he? And he'd married the heiress to a German sparkling wine firm. And this basically made him an absolute figure of fun in Britain when he became ambassador. And everybody said, look at this champagne salesman. That's what people said. He's a champagne salesman. I put it in my order.
他以前在英国工作过，在战前也在加拿大工作过。所以他会说英语，不是吗？他会说英语。他在大战中获得过铁十字勋章。所以他身体上相当勇敢，但后来他在酒水贸易中工作过，不是吗？他还娶了一个德国起泡酒公司继承人为妻。当他成为大使时，这基本上使他在英国成了一个绝对的笑柄。每个人都说，看看这个香槟推销员。人们就是这么说的。他是个香槟推销员。我把这记在我的账上。
Yeah, not even real champagne, right? German sparkling wine. Who wants that? No one. Oh dear. Imagine if the Nazis had one, the vengeance he'd have had. I've always said two things about Ruben Trott that are surprising that I learned from Richard Evans' recent book on the Nazis. First of all, he was a brilliant violinist. And secondly, he competed in the Canadian national figure skating championships. So that's a nice image. Yeah. The Torvalen Dean of the Nazi party. Exactly. Which one was he? Torvalen Dean. Anyway, he's Tonya Harding. Surely he's the Tonya Harding of figure skating.
是的，甚至不是真正的香槟，对吧？德国起泡酒。谁想要那个？没人。噢，天哪。想象一下，如果纳粹赢了，他会进行怎样的报复。关于里宾特洛甫，我一直觉得两件令人惊讶的事是从理查德·埃文斯最近关于纳粹的书里学到的。首先，他是一个出色的中小提琴手。其次，他参加了加拿大全国花样滑冰锦标赛。所以这是一个美好的画面。是的。纳粹党的托维尔与迪恩。完全正确。他是哪一个？托维尔还是迪恩？不管怎样，他肯定是托尼亚·哈丁。他绝对是花样滑冰界的托尼亚·哈丁。
That's harsh on Tonya Harding, who's subject to a very good film that made me more sympathetic to her. Okay, well fine. I apologise. You can't equate Margot Robbie to Ribbentrop. No, that's strange casting. That's not casting anyone. No, we want to put it on the record. I think you should just say you're not comparing Ribbentrop to Margot Robbie. I'm not comparing Margot Robbie and Joachim von Ribbentrop. I want
这对托尼亚·哈丁太苛刻了，她是一部非常好的电影的主角，那部电影让我对她产生了更多同情。好吧，好吧。我道歉。你不能把玛格特·罗比等同于里宾特洛甫。不，那是奇怪的选角。那不是选角任何人。不，我们想把它记录在案。我想你应该直接说你没有把里宾特洛甫和玛格特·罗比作比较。我没有把玛格特·罗比和约阿希姆·冯·里宾特洛甫作比较。我想
to be quite clear about that. Good. Okay. So Ribbentrop takes the hardest possible line at the foreign ministry. He always eggs Hitler on. He always says, you know, that's the way to Hitler's favor basically to be more of even more of a Nazi than Hitler is. And secondly, I think this is a really important point. Ribbentrop is completely blinded by his hatred of Britain. So he always says to Hitler, the British are absolutely spineless. They are the most pathetic, pitiful, curse, defeat. They will never fight because they're too busy making jokes about champagne salesmen and Savile Row.
把这一点说清楚。很好。好吧。因此，里宾特洛甫在外交部采取了极其强硬的路线。他总是煽动希特勒。他总是说，你知道，赢得希特勒青睐的方法基本上就是比希特勒表现得更像个纳粹。其次，我认为这是一个非常重要的观点。里宾特洛甫完全被他对英国的仇恨蒙蔽了双眼。所以他总是对希特勒说，英国人绝对是毫无骨气的。他们是最可悲、最可怜、遭天谴、一触即溃的。他们永远不会打仗，因为他们太忙于拿香槟推销员和萨维尔罗街开玩笑了。
And if we do ever fight them, we will crush them like insects underfoot. So he really eggs it. He gives Hitler very, very bad advice. And you know, who else is of course revealing to Hitler that Britain's air defence is not any good is Uniti Mipford. Yes, I wondered if she would make an unwanted appearance in this podcast, and she has. All right, so let's pick up the narrative. In March 1938, Hitler comes back from Vienna on the 15th of March to a tumultuous reception. He's had an amazing time in Austria, he's been to his boyhood house, he's addressed this enormous crowd, and barely has he returned
如果我们真的跟他们打仗，我们会像踩死昆虫一样碾碎他们。所以他真的在煽风点火。他给希特勒提供了非常非常糟糕的建议。而且你知道，还有谁当然向希特勒透露英国的防空力量其实不怎么样，那就是尤妮蒂·米特福德。是的，我想知道她是否会在这期播客中不请自来，而她确实来了。好吧，让我们继续推进叙事。1938年3月，希特勒于3月15日从维也纳返回，受到了热烈的欢迎。他在奥地利度过了一段美妙的时光，他去过自己童年时的住所，向这庞大的人群发表了演讲，而他刚一回来
then he gets out a map, Goebbels diary describes it, and they go over the map together and Hitler says, you know, I can't wait because basically I'm going to see, I realise now that I will see in my lifetime, the great German Reich, the German Empire over all Europe and all the world. And the next step is going to be Czechoslovakia. Because I write that with the Anschluss, so Austria is now part of a greater Reich, that Czechoslovakia is basically kind of sticking into the gut of this Reich. So purely on a map, it looks like it should be swallowed up. It's encircled. It's virtually encircled. Exactly right. And it's a kind of island of
就拿出一张地图，戈培尔的日记是这样描述的，他们一起仔细查看地图，希特勒说，你知道，我等不及了，因为基本上我要去看看，我现在意识到我将在我的有生之年看到伟大的德意志帝国，也就是统治全欧洲和全世界的德意志帝国。而下一步将是捷克斯洛伐克。因为我随德奥合并这样写道，所以奥地利现在是大德意志帝国的一部分，而捷克斯洛伐克基本上就像是插在这个帝国腹地里的一把尖刀。所以纯粹从地图上看，它看起来应该被吞并。它被包围了。它几乎被合围了。完全正确。而且它是一座
Slavs surrounded by or partially surrounded by a lot of Germans exactly. However, Czechoslovakia is also a pretty serious target, a much more serious target than Austria. It's bigger than Austria. It's got 15 million people. It was created from the Austro-Hungarian Empire. So Bohemia and Moravia from the Austrian bit and Slovakia from the Hungarian bit. It is by far the most sort of resilient liberal
斯拉夫人的孤岛，被许多德国人包围或部分包围。完全正确。然而，捷克斯洛伐克也是一个相当严肃的目标，是一个比奥地利严重得多的目标。它比奥地利更大。它拥有1500万人口。它是从奥匈帝国分裂出来的。所以波希米亚和摩拉维亚来自奥地利部分，斯洛伐克来自匈牙利部分。它是中欧迄今为止最具复原力的
democracy in Central Europe. It's got a very well-educated population. It has weathered the Depression reasonably well. It's got a really, really serious industrial base. I mean, I know Skoda became a joke in Britain in the 1980s. Not in Northumberland. Where everyone drives a Skoda became a joke in Britain in the 1980s, but not in Northumberland. Not in Northumberland. Where everyone drives a Skoda Yeti. Today? Yeah, Sadie Bull won. So pride and joy. So we're very pro Skoda. The other thing about Skoda... Are you touting for sponsorship? Is that what you're doing? If Skoda want to give us a free Yeti, we are, you know, we're here. But the other thing which I hadn't realized is that Skoda made
自由民主国家。它拥有受过良好教育的人口。它相当好地经受住了大萧条的考验。它拥有一个非常非常严肃的工业基础。我知道斯柯达在20世纪80年代的英国成了一个笑话。诺森伯兰郡可不是。每个人都开着斯柯达在80年代的英国成了一个笑话，但诺森伯兰郡可不这么认为。诺森伯兰郡可不这么认为。那里每个人都开斯柯达雪人（Skoda Yeti）。今天？是的，萨迪·布尔赢了。所以引以为豪。所以我们非常支持斯柯达。关于斯柯达的另一件事……你在拉赞助吗？你是这个意思吗？如果斯柯达想给我们免费送一辆雪人，我们（你知道的）随时奉陪。但另一件我之前没有意识到的是，斯柯达制造了
the Bren gum, which I always thought was British. The Skoda Works, which is in Pilsen in Western Czechoslovakia, is one of the largest industrial complexes in Europe. It is a really, really serious business. So a massive prize for a German economy on its uppers. It's a gigantic prize. If you're playing a board game, you're desperate to get this thing. They make tanks, they make the best guns, some of the best guns in Europe. Yeah, so the Braschami are using it. I mean, I'm amazed by that. Exactly. They make tanks, tools, ships, locomotives.
布伦机枪，我一直以为那是英国的。位于捷克斯洛伐克西南部比尔森的斯柯达工厂是欧洲最大的工业综合体之一。这是一项非常非常重大的业务。因此，对于一个处于破产边缘的德国经济来说，这是一个巨大的奖品。这是一个巨大的奖品。如果你在玩桌游，你一定会拼命想得到这个东西。他们制造坦克，他们制造最好的枪械，欧洲最好的一些枪械。是的，所以布拉查米（Braşami，疑为拼写错误或人名/地名误读，此处按音译）正在使用它。我的意思是，我对这一点感到惊讶。完全正确。他们制造坦克、工具、船只、机车。
They've got Lignite. They make loads and loads of stuff. And Czek Czechoslovakia therefore has this colossal military arsenal and a very, very well-trained and well-motivated army. And Dominic, don't they also on the borders where the kind of the mountains abut Germany, they've built a fairly impregnable series of defences. I mean, can you imagine a line but in a mountain chain? They have indeed. Their frontier defences. I mean, imagine a line, but in a mountain chain. They have indeed. Their frontier defences are pretty serious. They have a lot of raw
他们拥有褐煤。他们制造许许多多的东西。因此，捷克斯洛伐克拥有庞大的军事军火库以及一支训练有素、斗志昂扬的军队。多米尼克，在与德国接壤的边境山脉地区，他们不是也修建了一系列基本上坚不可摧的防御工事吗？我的意思是，你能想象一条横亘在山脉中的防线吗？他们的确修了。他们的边境防御工事。我的意思是，想象一条横亘在山脉中的防线。他们的确修了。他们的边境防御工事相当严密。他们拥有许多原材料。
materials. They have tungsten, they have uranium ore, I think it is. And Dominic, as I mentioned, lignite. I don't really know what that is, but whenever I see it in this kind of book, I want the lignite. And on top of that, the Czechs have two very serious allies, France, on the one hand, and the Soviet Union on the other. And the fact that France is an ally, if France goes to war, then Britain is obliged to go to war. Yeah, probably.
他们有钨，我想还有铀矿石。而且多米尼克，正如我提到的，还有褐煤。我其实不知道那是什么，但每当我在这种书里看到它时，我就想要那个褐煤。最重要的是，捷克人有两个非常严肃的盟友：一方面是法国，另一方面是苏联。而法国作为一个盟友的事实意味着，如果法国参战，英国也将被迫参战。是的，很可能是这样。
And so we're back to a kind of pre First World War, you know, mountaineers all tethered up by a single rope kind of thing. Yeah, exactly. So it's a tough nut to crack, right? On the other hand, if you could crack it, great, because these are the attractions. First of all, as you said, it, great, because these are the attractions. First of all, as you said, it's a rich Slav country that obtrudes into the Reich. So loads of Hitler's generals think, you know, I'd love to crush that. It's allied to France. So if there is ever a war, Czechoslovakia would fight and that would automatically mean Germany would face a war
所以我们又回到了第一次世界大战之前那种登山者们被一根绳子拴在一起的状况，诸如此类。是的，完全如此。所以这是一个很难啃的硬骨头，对吧？另一方面，如果你能啃下它，那就太棒了，因为这些就是吸引力所在。首先，正如你所说，它是一个富裕的斯拉夫国家，凸入到帝国内部。所以希特勒的许多将军都认为，你知道，我很想把它粉碎。它与法国结盟。所以如果有任何战争，捷克斯洛伐克将会参战，那将自动意味着德国将面临
on two fronts. So let's knock that out first. That makes sense. Will Barron And am I right also that Hitler has potential allies himself because both the Hungarians and the Poles have kind of irredentist ambitions. They want to carve out a chunk. Mason Hickman This is true of every country in Central Europe and it will become a really important theme. So the dream of the French in particular was always to put together a kind of Central European alliance against Hitler. But the problem with that is exactly the point that you've identified, that their neighbors
两线作战。所以让我们先把这个敲定。这说得通。威廉·巴伦（Will Barron）我说得对吗？希特勒自己也有潜在的盟友，因为匈牙利人和波兰人都对捷克斯洛伐克怀有收复失地的野心？他们想分一杯羹。梅森·希克曼（Mason Hickman）中欧的每一个国家都是如此，这将会成为一个非常重要的主题。因此，法国人的梦想一直是拼凑一个针对希特勒的中欧联盟。但其中的问题正是你所指出的那一点，他们的邻居
think, I quite fancy a bit of Czechoslovakia. Yeah, exactly. So that's going to be a real problem. The Germans obviously want, as you've already mentioned, they want Czechoslovakia's raw materials, they want the industry, they want the currency and stuff. For Hitler, I think it's also quite personal. He hates the Czechs and he hates them because he was Austrian. And if you were a German speaking Austrian before the First World War, the Czechs were basically your arch enemy within the empire. So they are the Slavs with whom Hitler had been, had had grown up, having a personal experience of.
心想：“我对捷克斯洛伐克挺感兴趣的。”是的，完全是这样。所以这将是一个真正的问题。正如你已经提到的，德国人显然希望得到捷克斯洛伐克的原材料、工业、货币等等。对希特勒来说，我认为这也是相当个人的。他讨厌捷克人，他讨厌他们是因为他是奥地利人。如果你是一战前讲德语的奥地利人，捷克人基本上就是你在帝国内部的死敌。所以他们是希特勒在成长过程中曾有过亲身接触的斯拉夫人。
Exactly. So not the Poles. Not the Poles. This will surprise people. Hitler has no kind of prior with the Poles. He doesn't care about the Poles. He's never had any dealings with them. For him, it's the Czechs. But also he has a kind of artist's yearning to ride in triumph through Prague, doesn't he? This great, beautiful city with its incredible churches and of course synagogues, the great castle. So a bit like Paris, I guess, it kind of haunts his imagination as a foreign city that he would love to have as a prize. He has that sort of slightly adolescent Wagner-loving fantasy,
完全正确。所以不是波兰人。不是波兰人。这会让人感到意外。希特勒对波兰人没有任何先入为主的成见。他不在乎波兰人。他从来没有同他们打过交道。对他的而言，是捷克人。但同时他也有着一种艺术家的渴望，想要以胜利者的姿态骑马穿过布拉格，不是吗？这座宏伟美丽的城市拥有令人难以置信的教堂，当然还有犹太会堂以及伟大的城堡。所以有点像巴黎，我猜，它作为一座他渴望作为战利品拥有的外国城市，萦绕在他的想象中。他有着那种略带青春期的、热爱瓦格纳的幻想，
I will ride through Prague as a conqueror. You know, that kind of thing. He absolutely has it. At Tavallain. Yes, exactly. So as Lug would have it, going back to the speech that you began the episode, he has a perfect pretext for German action, because the great flaw of Woodrow Wilson's project after the First World War of self-determination and all these new nation states was there are so many minorities. And in Czechoslovakia, there are three million German speakers who live along the Western border, this area known as the Sudetenland. Now they have never been Germans. They were Austrian subjects. But obviously in this world of nationalism, of new nation states, their
我将以征服者的身份骑马穿过布拉格。你知道，那种调调。他绝对有这种想法。在塔瓦兰（Tavallain，疑为口误）。是的，完全如此。因此，正如命运的安排，回到你开场时发表的那番演讲，他有了一个完美的德国采取行动的借口，因为伍德罗·威尔逊在一战后关于民族自决和所有这些新民族国家的主张的巨大缺陷在于，有太多的少数群体。而在捷克斯洛伐克，沿着西部边境生活着三百万讲德语的人，也就是被称为苏台德的这个地区。这些人从来都不是德国人。他们是奥地利臣民。但显然在这个民族主义、新民族国家的世界里，他们的
German-ness, the fact they speak German becomes a massive issue for them. Now they're pretty well treated, they're probably better treated than any other minority in Europe. They have full legal equality with their Czech neighbours. The Czechs don't massively discriminate against them. But they've been quite hard hit by the Depression, so a lot of them have been put out of work. And secondly, of course, over the border, they've got this bloke ranting and raving about German-dom and saying he's going to build a greater German Reich. So obviously a lot of them think, quite fancy being part of that.
德国属性——他们说德语这一事实——对他们来说成了一个巨大问题。现在他们受到了相当好的待遇，他们可能比欧洲任何其他少数群体受到的待遇都要好。他们与捷克邻居享有完全的法律平等。捷克人并没有对他们进行大规模的歧视。但他们在大萧条中受创颇重，所以他们当中很多人失业了。其次，当然，在国界那边，有这家伙在大肆叫嚣德意志同胞情谊，并说他要建立一个更伟大的德意志帝国。所以很显然，他们中的许多人会想，还挺想成为其中的一部分的。
And the main Sudeten German party is led by this bloke who was an Austrian war veteran called Konrad Henlein, who also, I have to say, was a gymnastics instructor. And as I think of it, he's a PE teacher. Well, he's, but I mean, more than that, he's a racist PE teacher. He's a racist PE teacher. They're the worst kind of PE teacher. Yeah. And actually the worst kind of racists. So he's a bad man. Yeah. He's a bad man, Conrad Henlein. So he's the leader of the Sudeten German party and he says, oh, let's basically get into bed with Hitler.
主要的苏台德德国人党由这个名叫康拉德·亨莱因的奥地利退伍老兵领导，我也必须指出，他曾是一名体操教练。当我想到这一点时，他就是一个体育老师。好吧，他是，但我的意思是，不仅如此，他是一个种族主义体育老师。他是一个种族主义体育老师。他们是最糟糕的那种体育老师。是的，也是最糟糕的那种种族主义者。所以他是个坏人。是的。他是个坏人，康拉德·亨莱因。所以他是苏台德德国人党的领袖，他说，哦，让我们基本上跟希特勒搞到一起去吧。
So Hitler, as soon as he gets back from the Angeles, he sets the wheels in motion. He gets Henlein to Berlin for a secret meeting and he says, right, I want to sort this out. Like I'm going to start agitating for you. Let's get you all riled up. So a month later, April, 1938, Henlein gets his party together and he says, oh, we're being totally bullied by the Czechs. We want total self-government. We want autonomy and all this.
所以希特勒一从奥地利回来，就立刻把事情付诸行动。他把亨莱因请到柏林进行秘密会面，并说，好，我想解决这个问题。我会开始为你煽动。让我们把你们的斗志都调动起来。所以一个月后，即1938年4月，亨莱因把他的党召集起来说，哦，我们正受到捷克人的彻底欺凌。我们要完全的自治。我们要自治权以及所有这一切。
Now, the important thing here is they don't, this is not the aim. The aim is actually to dismember the whole of Czechoslovakia. This is just a pretext. So Czechoslovakia said, oh, brilliant, well, you can have autonomy. That's not good enough. Hitler be furious. That's not what they want. They want to give the Czechs a load of demands they can't possibly answer. So make them so humiliating that there's no way that the Czech government can possibly
现在，这里最重要的事情是，他们的目的并非如此，这不是他们的目标。真正的目标是肢解整个捷克斯洛伐克。这只是一个借口。所以捷克斯洛伐克说，哦，太棒了，好吧，你们可以自治。这还不够。希特勒会大发雷霆。这不是他们想要的。他们想要向捷克人提出一堆根本无法答应的要求。所以要让这些要求极其屈辱，以至于捷克政府根本不可能
accept them. A little bit like that Austrian ultimatum to Serbia before the first world war, remember? So meanwhile, Hitler gets his commanders together and he says, I want you to draw up plans for the invasion of Czechoslovakia. Again, worth emphasizing, this is not just about the Sudetenland. He wants the whole country. He says to the head of the Wehrmacht,acht guy called Wilhelm Keitel, he says, I want the whole
接受它们。这有点像一战前奥地利对塞尔维亚发出的最后通牒，记得吗？所以与此同时，希特勒把他的指挥官们召集到一起，他说，我要你们制定入侵捷克斯洛伐克的计划。再次值得强调的是，这不仅仅关乎苏台德地区。他想要整个国家。他对国防军最高指挥官、一个叫威廉·凯特尔的家伙说，我要整个
country as a launch pad for the showdown in the East with Bolshevism. So he's still thinking beyond this, right? They're fighting the USSR. And he also says, when we do invade, I want the whole thing done and dusted in four days, because I don't want to give the British and the French, I don't want a European war with Britain and France. I don't want to give them a chance. I want to present them with a fait accompli so that they don't get stuck in as well.
国家作为向东与布尔什维克决战的跳板。所以他想得更长远，对吧？他们要与苏联作战。他还说，当我们入侵时，我希望整个行动在四天内速战速决，因为我不想给英国和法国机会，我不希望与英法爆发一场欧洲战争。我不想给他们机会。我要给他们制造一个既成事实，这样他们也就无法插手了。
But at this point, he says, this is a long-term thing. We're not going to rush this. This could be like a year or a couple of years, who knows. But then something happens that massively advances his timetable. It's a slightly complicated and weird story, but basically there are local elections in the Sudetenland. There are some scuffles. At the same time, the Germans' army are having maneuvers, just ordinary kind of military maneuvers, nothing sinister in it. And the Czechs get in a massive kind of funk and mobilize their reserves. They think the Germans
但在这一点上，他说，这是一个长期的事情。我们不急于求成。这可能需要一年或几年，谁知道呢。但随后发生了一件事，极大地推进了他的时间表。这是一个有点复杂且奇怪的故事，但基本上是苏台德地区举行了地方选举。发生了一些冲突。与此同时，德国军队正在进行军事演习，只是一般的军事演习，没有什么不怀好意的地方。而捷克人陷入了一种极度的恐慌，并动员了他们的预备役。他们以为德国人
are about to attack them. And actually, weirdly, this is the one time Hitler's not going to attack them. And as a result of this, there's all sorts of sort of diplomatic excitement, rows between ambassadors and stuff. There's a huge row between Ribbentrop and the British ambassador, the British ambassador. Are you going to attack Czechoslovakia? What are you doing? So the British ambassador, he's Sir Neville Henderson. And he's, I think, the first of two British performers in this story who don't turn up absolutely brill's Sir Neville Henderson. And he's I think the first of two British performers in this story who don't turn up absolutely brilliantly called Neville. If you're called Neville, it's not good for you. And he is basically a guy who is calculated
就要攻击他们了。说来也怪，这恰恰是希特勒唯一一次不打算攻击他们的时候。结果，各种各样的外交轰动随之而来，大使之间争吵不休。里宾特洛普与英国大使之间爆发了一场巨大的争端，英国大使。你们要进攻捷克斯洛伐克吗？你们在干什么？所以这位英国大使，他是内维尔·亨德森爵士。我想他是这个故事中两个表现绝对不出彩的英国演员中的第一位，叫内维尔的人绝对不出彩。如果你叫内维尔，这对你可没什么好处。他基本上是一个
to rub Ribbentrop up the wrong way because he has impeccable tailoring. He's always seen wearing a carnation. In fact, did you know his uncle married Alice in Wonderland? So Alice Little. Really? Yeah. And he's kind of the embodiment of an English gentleman. Yeah, Ribbentrop would hate that. He likes going shooting, so would get on very well with Goering. In fact, does get on very well with Goering. They all go off and kind of shoot elk together. But in all kinds of
注定会让里宾特洛普很不爽的家伙，因为他剪裁考究，衣着无可挑剔。人们总是看到他佩戴着一朵康乃馨。事实上，你知道吗，他的叔叔娶了《爱丽丝梦游仙境》里的爱丽丝？也就是爱丽丝·利德尔。真的吗？是的。他有点像是英国绅士的化身。是的，里宾特洛普会讨厌那样的。他喜欢去打猎，所以会和戈林很合得来。事实上，他和戈林确实很合得来。他们一起去打过马鹿什么的。但在方方面面，
ways, he's a terrible man to have sent to Berlin because there's no way that Ribbentrop will get on with him. And in fact, I think, am I right that he has been sent because he's basically the person in the foreign office who people think he is most sympathetic to autocracies. Yeah. He's an archer piece actually is what he is. Neville Henderson, which is then ironic that Ribbentrop and him don't really get along. Because they have a massive row at this point. Henderson says, if you're really going to attack, I mean, you mad to attack Czechoslovakia because France will fight
他被派往柏林实在是一个糟糕的人选，因为里宾特洛普根本不可能跟他合得来。事实上，我是不是说得对，他被派去是因为他基本上是外交部里被认为对独裁政权最同情的人。是的。他其实是个十足的混蛋，这就是内维尔·亨德森，讽刺的是，里宾特洛普后来却跟他合不来。因为他们在这个问题上大吵了一架。亨德森说，如果你们真的要进攻，我是说，你们进攻捷克斯洛伐克就疯了，因为法国会参战，
and they will have to fight you. And Ribbentrop goes absolutely mental and says, well, that would be the greatest defeat in French history. And if Britain were to join France, once again, we'll fight you to the death. That's not a harmonious relationship. Well, this is what comes when people who have different views on tailoring get to meet up in the charteries of Europe. Exactly. Never have a champagne salesman. I mean, that's basically the, don't get involved with champagne salesmen or NDP teachers. Right, Ribbentrop tells all this to Hitler and Hitler is absolutely furious. He's outraged at the loss of prestige. You know, he sees this as a complete humiliation. The Czechs immobilized their army, the British have all kicked off, whatever.
而且他们不得不与你们作战。里宾特洛普勃然大怒，说道，那将是法国历史上最大的失败。如果英国加入法国，我们将再次同你们血战到底。这不是一种和谐的关系。好吧，当对剪裁有不同看法的人们在欧洲的酒馆里相遇时，就会发生这种事。没错。千万别找香槟推销员。我的意思是，基本上就是，不要跟香槟推销员或民族社会主义德国工人党教师扯上关系。好吧，里宾特洛普把这一切都告诉了希特勒，希特勒勃然大怒。他对声誉的丧失感到愤怒。你知道，他认为这是一次彻底的屈辱。捷克人动员了军队，英国人也大动干戈，诸如此类。
And he says to his aides, I can't live like this. We have to solve this problem now. And he spends the next week at his eerie, the eagle's nest in Berchtesgaden on top of this mountain. And then he comes back on the 28th of May, 1938 to Berlin and he summons his generals and he says, okay, I've come to a decision. We need to get this started.
他对助手们说，我没法这样生活了。我们必须现在就解决这个问题。他在贝希特斯加登山顶的鹰巢隐蔽所度过了接下来的一周。然后，在1938年5月28日，他回到柏林，召集了将领们说，好吧，我做出了决定。我们需要开始行动了。
I want my living space, my Lebensraum. We're going to have to strike East eventually. And because of this, he says one day we're going to have to fight France and Britain. But in that case, we can't have the Czechs hanging around on the other side. So we have to knock them out first. And he says, I quote, I am utterly determined that Czechoslovakia should disappear from the map. And two days later, Keitel presents him with the finalized plan. It's called Falgrun, Case Green.
我想要我的生存空间，我的“生存空间”。我们迟早要向东进攻。正因如此，他说总有一天我们要与法英作战。但在这种情况下，我们不能让捷克人在另一边碍事。所以我们必须先消灭他们。他说，我引用原话：“我坚决主意要让捷克斯洛伐克从地图上消失。”两天后，凯特尔向他提交了最终敲定的计划。这被称为“绿色方案”（Fall Grün）。
And the preface to the plan lays out the explicit aim, quote, to smash Czechoslovakia by military action. So the stage is set for war. I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we will see what the upshot is. Hi, everyone. It's Cathy here from The Rest Is Politics US. Anthony Scaramucci and I want to tell you about our new series that looks at one of the darkest days in modern American history, the Capitol riots of January the 6th. You know, four years have passed since Donald Trump supporters stormed the Capitol building and tried to overturn the 2020 election results.
该计划的前言明确提出了明确的目标，引述：“通过军事行动粉碎捷克斯洛伐克。”战争的舞台已经搭好。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将看看结果如何。大家好。我是来自《权力的代价：美国》的凯蒂。安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇和我想要向你们讲述我们的新系列节目，它聚焦于现代美国历史上最黑暗的日子之一——1月6日的国会山骚乱。你知道，自特朗普支持者冲击国会山并试图推翻2020年选举结果以来，已经过去了四年。
And Katty and I are going to explore the tensions and the personalities at the heart of that storm. Yeah, we're going to look at the whole story, starting off with, of course, the 2020 election result itself, Joe Biden's victory, Donald Trump's attempts to undermine that result right up until January the 6th and those horrifying scenes that all of us watched on television back then. So don't miss it. Go and search The Rest Is Politics US wherever you get your podcast to hear just how Donald Trump tried to defy American democracy. And we've included a clip from the series for you to listen to at the end of this episode.
凯蒂和我将探讨那场风暴核心的紧张局势和各方人物。是的，我们将审视整个故事，首先当然是2020年的选举结果本身、乔·拜登的胜利、唐纳德·特朗普试图破坏这一结果的种种举动，直到1月6日以及当年我们所有人在电视上看到的那些骇人听闻的场景。所以千万不要错过。请在任何你获取播客的地方搜索《权力的代价：美国》，听听唐纳德·特朗普是如何试图对抗美国民主的。我们在这集节目的最后为你们准备了一段该系列的节目片段供大家收听。
Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are looking at the development of the Munich crisis. Hitler wants to dismember Czechoslovakia and Dominic, we heard just before the break how he summoned his generals, told them, draw up a plan. Let's get on with this. What happens next? Well, Tom O'Rourke says, your first take of that, you confused me with that of Hitler. I did. Which I think people who enjoy my journalism will appreciate that. That's Freudian slip. You know that the German gym teacher, he wrote for the Daily Mail. Conrad Henlein.
哈喽，欢迎回到《权力的历史》。我们正在关注慕尼黑危机的演变。希特勒想要肢解捷克斯洛伐克，多米尼克，就在刚才休息前我们听说他是如何召集将领，让他们制定计划的。让我们继续。接下来发生了什么？好吧，汤姆·奥鲁克说，你对那件事的第一反应，把我跟希特勒混为一谈了。我是这么做了。我想欣赏我新闻报道的人会对此有所体会。那是口误。你知道那个德国体育老师，他为《每日邮报》写过文章。康拉德·亨lein。
Yeah. They featured a splash from him and he came out of it very badly. Really? Just as Conrad wrote for the Daily Mail. And he was in the RRC. You Joseph Conrad wrote for the Daily Mail. And he wasn't Nazi. And you, so you, Conrad and this P teacher. Right. So you ask about Hitler's generals, what they make of all this. Quite a lot of people from the very beginning are very, very
是的。他们刊登了一篇关于他的重磅报道，而他的下场非常糟糕。真的吗？就像康拉德为《每日邮报》写文章一样。他还在RRC（英国陆军预备役部队）。你约瑟夫·康拉德为《每日邮报》写文章。而且他不是纳粹。而你，所以，康拉德和这个体育老师。好吧。那么你问到希特勒的将军们，他们对这一切有什么看法？从一开始，相当多的人就非常、非常
worried about Hitler's ambitions. There's no sense that the German people want a war. So as we will discover in this whole of the series in the next couple of weeks, all that Nazi indoctrination has not been as successful as Hitler hoped. Well, can I also ask you about whether there is, so quite aside from the fact, do they want to go and conquer a country that does not contain German speakers? Do they feel any sense of kind of identity with the Sudeten Germans? I mean, do they feel this is their kith and kin?
担心希特勒的野心。没有任何迹象表明德国人民想要一场战争。因此，正如我们在这几周的整个系列节目中所发现的那样，所有这些纳粹洗脑并没有像希特勒希望的那样成功。嗯，我还可以问你吗，这里是否存在，抛开事实不谈，他们是否想去征服一个不包含德语使用者的国家？他们对苏台德德国人有一种认同感吗？我的意思是，他们觉得这是他们的骨肉同胞吗？
I think it's the classic thing that some people who care about such things work themselves up into a lather about it. Oh, it's terrible that fellow German speakers are being poorly treated. I mean, that is a big theme in German newspapers in the 1920s and 1930s, but also probably most people are never particularly bothered about other people, are they? I mean, a dog that doesn't bark in the night is the Germans in the Tyrol, which is part of Italy. Yes. And they are, they're much worse treated, aren't they? But nobody seems to raise a pipe about them. But it's a question about what the newspapers, what Goebbels' propaganda machine alights on, isn't it? So Goebbels' propaganda machine will
我认为这是一个经典现象，一些关心这种事情的人会对此大惊小怪、激动不已。哦，同为德语使用者的人受到虐待，这太糟糕了。我的意思是，这是20世纪20和30年代德国报纸的一个重大主题，但可能大多数人从来没有真正特别在意过其他人，对吧？我的意思是，那只在夜里没有叫的狗就是蒂罗尔的德国人，蒂罗尔是意大利的一部分。是的。他们的待遇要糟糕得多，不是吗？但似乎没有人为他们鸣不平。但这是一个关于报纸、戈培尔的宣传机器聚焦于什么的问题，对吧？所以戈培尔的宣传机器会
run news stories day after day about the plight of the Sudeten Germans and hammer it home into people's minds. The fact that the Germans, you know, go on and on about the Sudeten Germans, but not the ones in the Tyrol. They don't really care about them. I mean, is this all just a, I mean, do they passionately believe in that? I mean, or is it just an excuse? Yeah, it's an excuse. I think if it never come up in the newspapers, people wouldn't be walking around the streets of Hamburg saying, you know, I often think about the Sudetenland and the Sudeten Germans. But I was wondering about the Nazi high command, the fact that they don't raise a peep over the Tyrol Germans, but the Sudeten Germans, they do. Are they just using them or do they
日复一日地播报关于苏台德德国人困境的新闻报道，并将其深深烙印在人们的脑海中。事实上，德国人，你知道，喋喋不休地谈论苏台德德国人，却不谈蒂罗尔的那些人。他们其实并不在乎他们。我的意思是，这全都是一个，我的意思是，他们真的对此深信不疑吗？还是仅仅是一个借口？是的，这只是个借口。我想如果报纸上从来没有提过这件事，人们是不会走在汉堡的街头说，你知道的，我经常想起苏台德地区和苏台德德国人的。但我在想纳粹高级指挥部，他们对蒂罗尔的德国人一声不吭，但对苏台德德国人却反应强烈。他们只是在利用他们，还是真的
genuinely think that this is disgraceful? I think a lot of them ideally would love to have the Sudeten Germans in a greater, they'd like to have every German speaker in a greater German right. Because I suppose it gives them more manpower as well, doesn't it? Yeah, and they believe in it ideologically. As regards to the Germans in the Tyrol and Northern Italy, they probably just think, well... More important to keep Mussolini onside. More important to keep Mussolini onside. But to go back to the thing about what people
认为这是一种耻辱？我认为他们中的许多人在理想情况下很想把苏台德德国人纳入大德意志。他们希望大德意志帝国里有每一个德语使用者。因为我想这也给他们带来了更多的人力，不是吗？是的，他们在意识形态上信仰这一点。至于蒂罗尔和意大利北部的德国人，他们可能只是觉得，嗯…… 维持墨索里尼站在我们这边更重要。维持墨索里尼站在我们这边更重要。但回到关于人们
think about Hitler's war plans, a lot of the traditional conservatives, including actually people like Hermann Görering, I mean, who's not a traditional conservative, he really is a Nazi, but they're quite anxious about it. They're like, really? Risk war with France? Goering's kind of torn, isn't he? Because he does want all the arms fact, factures and the lignite and stuff. I mean, that would be brilliant because that would help out his various four-year plans or whatever they are, five-year plans. But obviously he doesn't want Germany to be crushed by no written in France. He's very going as we shall see in this series is extremely anxious about fighting Britain
对希特勒战争计划的看法的那一点，许多传统保守派，实际上包括像赫尔曼·戈林这样的人——我的意思是，他不是传统保守派，他确实是个纳粹分子——但他们对此相当焦虑。他们会想，真的吗？冒着与法国开战的风险？戈林其实挺纠结的，不是吗？因为他的确想要所有的武器工厂、褐煤什么的。我的意思是，那太棒了，因为那将有助于他的各种四年计划或诸如此类的五年计划。但显然后来他不希望德国被英法彻底击垮。正如我们将在本系列中看到的，戈林对与英法作战
and France. But above all, it's actually some of the generals who are really, really disturbed about it. So the chief among them is the army chief of staff who is a guy called General Ludwig Beck. So he was very experienced general. He was very pro-Nazi. He's not a Nazi member, but he's, he really believes in the sort of making Germany great again project. If you've seen the film Valkyrie with Tom Cruise playing Stauffenberg, he's Terence Stamp in this film. And Beck, he kind of likes the idea of fighting Czechoslovakia, but he thinks,
感到极其焦虑。但最重要的是，实际上是一些将军，他们对此感到非常、非常不安。所以其中最主要的是陆军参谋长，一个叫路德维希·贝克（Ludwig Beck）将军的家伙。所以他是一位非常有经验的将军。他非常支持纳粹。他不是纳粹党员，但他真的相信让德国再次伟大的那种项目。如果你看过汤姆·克鲁斯饰演施陶芬贝格的电影《行动目标希特勒》，他在这部电影里由特伦斯·斯坦普饰演。贝克，他有点喜欢与捷克斯洛伐克作战的想法，但他想，
whoa, we are going way too fast here. This will mean war with France and therefore with Britain, and we will definitely lose. He's the chief of staff of the army. He's a serious person. So all summer, he is firing off memos saying, this is a dreadful idea. We shouldn't do this. The thing is, he is seen as a doomsday. And the younger officers in particular say, oh, this old man, he's too pessimistic, all of this kind of thing. And even people who agree with him are nervous about going along with him because, of course, ever since the night of the long knives, they've sworn a personal oath of loyalty to the Fuhrer. So they can't disobey
哇，我们节奏太快了。这意味着将与法国开战，进而与英国开战，我们肯定会输。他是陆军参谋长。他是个严肃的人。所以整个夏天，他都在不断发出备忘录，说这主意太糟了。我们不该这么做。问题是，他被视为一个悲观主义者。尤其是年轻军官们说，哦，这个老头，他太悲观了，诸如此类的话。甚至那些同意他观点的人也很害怕顺从他，因为当然了，自从长刀之夜以来，他们已经向元首宣誓了个人效忠。所以他们不敢违抗
the Fuhrer or go against him. Anyway, what's very bad for Beck is in June they hold war games and the war games suggest that actually Hitler's plan might work. They could beat Czechoslovakia in 10, 11 days and even if they were then fighting France they could then transfer troops to the Western Front and hold back the French. When the result of these war games comes in Beck sees this and he says, oh god this is terrible, this is going to happen. He says to his fellow generals, we should all resign collectively. That will force Hitler's hand, get him to back down. He says desperate times require desperate measures or something like that. Some famous
元首或与他作对。无论如何，对贝克来说非常糟糕的是，他们在6月举行了军事演习，而军事演习表明，实际上希特勒的计划可能会成功。他们可以在10到11天内击败捷克斯洛伐克，即使他们随后与法国作战，他们也可以将部队调往西线并阻挡法国人。当这些军事演习的结果出来时，贝克看到后说，哦天哪，这太糟了，这要发生了。他对同僚将军们说，我们应该集体辞职。这会逼迫希特勒出手，让他退缩。他说，危急关头需采取非常手段，或者类似的话。一些名言。
line. And we have to save the fatherland from destruction. Exactly that. And the other generals say, no, if you want to resign, you resign. I'm not resigning. So he resigns in August. And this is actually a massive, massive lost opportunity in the story of stopping Hitler, because Beck is persuaded by Hitler to basically resign privately, not make a huge political fuss about it. Because Hitler says to him, look, this will play into the hands of Germany's enemies. And actually, if Beck had played his cards differently, who knows? There are loads of senior Nazis who felt very anxious about the, the rush to war.
我们必须把祖国从毁灭中拯救出来。正是如此。而其他将军则说，不，如果你想辞职，你就自己辞职。我可不辞职。于是他在8月辞职了。这实际上是阻止希特勒故事中一个巨大、巨大的失误，因为贝克被希特勒说服基本上进行了私下辞职，没有大张旗鼓地搞政治抗议。因为希特勒对他说，看，这会落入德国敌人的手中。其实，如果贝克当时换一种方式打出手中的牌，谁知道呢？有大量的纳粹高级官员对这种
And maybe, you know, who knows if he'd gone public, things might have been different. Goering is the new Fuhrer. Exactly. Anyway, he keeps his resignation secret. And actually here's a really interesting thing. his resignation secrets. And actually here's a really interesting thing. The late summer, the autumn of 1938, Beck and other senior people in the regime get together and they construct a plot to topple Hitler, to have a coup in Berlin. They say, look, we've achieved so much, he's actually now going too far and he's going to risk it all. They make sort
仓促开战感到非常焦虑。也许，如果他公开表态，事情可能会有所不同。戈林成了新元首。确实如此。无论如何，他将自己的辞职秘而不宣。实际上这里有一件非常有趣的事。他将辞职秘而不宣。实际上这里有一件非常有趣的事。1938年夏末秋初，贝克和政权内部的其他高级人物聚在一起，密谋推翻希特勒，在柏林发动一场政变。他们说，看，我们已经取得了如此多的成就，他现在实际上走得太远了，他将把一切都置于危险之中。他们建立了一种
of informal links, particularly with the British. You know, if we did topple Hitler, would you, would you be on side? So the head of military intelligence, Admiral Canaris is in on this. The former finance minister, the guy who's the most respected financier and industrialist in, in Germany, who's a guy called Hjalmar Schacht. What's he called, Dominic? He's called Hjalmar Schacht. What's he called, Dominic? He's called Hjalmar Schacht, Tom. Good.
非正式的联系，尤其是与英国人。你知道，如果我们真的推翻了希特勒，你们会支持吗？所以军事情报局长卡纳里斯海军上将也参与其中。前财政部长、德国最受尊敬的金融家和实业家、一个叫亚尔马·沙赫特（Hjalmar Schacht）的家伙。他叫什么名字，多米尼克？他叫亚尔马·沙赫特。他叫什么名字，多米尼克？他叫亚尔马·沙赫特，汤姆。很好。
Yeah, you didn't think I could pronounce that twice in a row, but you were mistaken. You were mistaken. You showed me wrong. You thought it was the Schleswig-Holstein all over again. But no. So they get this plot together. A guy called Lieutenant Colonel Hans Oster, who's a counterintelligence chief, he draws up the blueprint for storming
是的，你以为我不能连续读对两遍，但你错了。你错了。你证明我错了。你以为这又是一次石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因事件。但并没有。所以他们策划了这个阴谋。一个叫汉斯·奥斯特（Hans Oster）的中校，他是反间谍主管，拟定了冲击
the Reich Chancellery, killing Hitler, possibly bringing back the monarchy. So it's the Kaiser who's in exile in Holland. Is he on this or not? I'm not sure he's as in on it as, yeah, he's not like pulling the strings. Because Hitler hates the monarchy by this point, doesn't he? Because he's just been to Rome where he feels he's been humiliated by the king of Italy that's right because exactly the king of Italy did not treat him as an eagle but yes it was a commoner yes and Hitler did not like this exactly so the big question I guess is could this
帝国总理府、刺杀希特勒、甚至可能恢复君主制的蓝图。那么流亡荷兰的德皇是否参与其中？我不确定他是否参与其中，是的，他并没有在幕后操纵。因为希特勒此时已经恨透了君主制，不是吗？因为他刚刚去过罗马，在那里他觉得自己被意大利国王羞辱了，没错，因为确实意大利国王没有把他当成雄鹰一样对待，是的，那只是个平民，是的，而希特勒并不喜欢这样，没错，所以最大的问题我想是这个
plot of worked because this is a real what-if and my answer probably is that it couldn't because they did try something similar the Valkyrie plot in 1944 and that didn't work at all I think the big issue for them though is that if Hitler could somehow get Czechoslovakia without having a world war, they would look like total mugs. Yeah. Exactly. So let's see if he can do that. That's summer 1938.
阴谋能成功吗？因为这是一个真正的“如果”，而我的回答很可能是不能，因为他们在1944年尝试过类似的“瓦尔基里”行动，结果根本没有成功。我认为对他们来说最大的问题是，如果希特勒能不知怎么在没有世界大战的情况下得到捷克斯洛伐克，他们看起来就会像彻底的傻瓜。是的。完全如此。所以让我们看看他能不能做到这一点。那是1938年夏天。
Hitler spends it at the eagle's nest. So this is his eerie in Berkater's garden in the south of Germany. He does his usual routine, loafing around, watching film, terrible films, talking to Albert Speer about architecture until like, basically he stays up very late doing nothing. So in other words, he has Theo's life. He conducts himself like Theo. Except Theo, of course, is not hanging out with the Mitford sister, which Hitler is. And I think this is when he's seeing her most of all. They go to Bayreuth together,
希特勒在鹰巢度过这段时间。所以这是他在德国南部贝希特斯加登的隐蔽所。他重复着他日常的例行公事：闲逛、看电影，看那些糟糕的电影，和阿尔伯特·施佩尔谈论建筑，直到基本上熬夜到很晚什么也不做。换句话说，他过着西奥的生活。他的行为就像西奥。当然，除了西奥没有跟米特福德姐妹鬼混，而希特勒有。我想这就是他跟她见得最多的时候。他们一起去拜罗伊特，
to Wagner, and then they have to leave early because Hitler wants to go to a gymnastics contest. He takes unity to that as well. I don't know whether the Sudetenland guy, whether the PE teacher is there. There's far too much gymnastics in this. It's a warning from history, Dominic. Yeah. And actually Hitler spends his time when he's doing any work, he does it on absolutely inconsequential things. In Kershaw lists the stuff that Hitler was doing that summer in 1938. Punishment for traffic offences, considerations of whether all cigarettes should be made nicotine free. The air would not like that. Or the type of holes to be put into flagpoles.
去看瓦格纳的歌剧，然后他们不得不提前离开，因为希特勒想去看体操比赛。他还带了尤妮蒂一起去。我不知道苏台德那个家伙，那个体育老师当时在不在。这里面的体操运动实在太多了。这是来自历史的警告，多米尼克。是的。实际上，希特勒在工作时，他把时间都花在绝对微不足道的事情上。伊恩·克肖列出了希特勒在1938年夏天所做的事情。惩罚交通违法行为、考虑是否应该让所有香烟都变成无尼古丁的。空气可不会喜欢那样。或者旗杆上应该打什么样孔。
Yeah, that's not very Third Reich, is it? No, no. Not what comes into mind when you think of the might of the Nazi state. That's Jimmy Carter's approach to the administration. That's what that is. Anyway, this is actually all a front. Hitler is fooling the world because all the time he is waiting for the attack on Czechoslovakia. He has set a date of the 1st of October and he says that's when we'll go in. He's absolutely convinced that the Western Allies will do nothing about it. And do you know what? He's right. They won't. First of all, the Czechs, two main allies, the Soviet Union, ally number one,
是的，那可不太像第三帝国的作风，对吧？不，不。当你想到纳粹国家的强大时，脑海中浮现的可不是这个。那是吉米·卡特的行政风格。那就是那回事。无论如何，这实际上全都是一个幌子。希特勒在愚弄世界，因为他一直在等待对捷克斯洛伐克的进攻。他已经设定了10月1日为日期，并表示那是我们进军的时候。他坚信西方盟友不会对此采取任何行动。你知道吗？他是对的。他们不会的。首先，捷克人的两个主要盟友，苏联（盟友一号），
Stalin has just started purging the Red Army. So he started killing all the officers in the Red Army. The last thing that Stalin wants is a war. So Stalin's not all the officers in the Red Army. The last thing that Stalin wants is a war. So Stalin's not going to fight. And secondly, the French. France is going through massive internal political ructions because the Popular Front has just come to power, which is the kind of left-wing organization. And that has provoked a huge sort of backlash on the right. So there's a sense in which French politics is pulling towards the extremes. There's a lot of overheated stuff, you know, oh, is there going to be a French civil war, Spanish civil war?
斯大林刚刚开始对红军进行大清洗。所以他开始屠杀红军中的所有军官。斯大林最不希望看到的就是战争。所以斯大林才不会呢，不是所有的红军军官。斯大林最不希望看到的就是战争。所以斯大林是不会参战的。其次，法国。法国正在经历巨大的内部政治动荡，因为人民阵线刚刚上台，这是一种左翼组织。而这引发了右翼的巨大强烈反弹。所以某种程度上，法国政治正被拉向极端。有很多过热的言论，你知道，哦，会有法国内战吗，西班牙内战吗？
Of course there isn't. And all of this means is that the French basically are in no kind of psychological condition to get stuck into a rerun of the Great War. Which means that Britain isn't either. Which means that if the French go in, that British definitely won't go in because as we'll see the British, basically when it comes to it, don't give a damn about Czechoslovakia. So all that summer, Goebbels fires up his propaganda machine. This goes back to the question you were asking, Tom.
当然不会。所有这一切意味着，法国基本上在心理上完全没有条件去卷入第一次世界大战的重演。这意味着英国也没有。这意味着如果法国参战，英国绝对不会参战，因为正如我们将看到的，英国人在关键时刻根本不在乎捷克斯洛伐克。所以整个夏天，戈培尔都在开动他的宣传机器。这就回到了你刚才问的问题，汤姆。
Do people care? They care when you shove it in their face day after day. When on the front page of the newspapers, it's Sudeten Germans are being attacked, they're being beaten, the Czechs will run them over in the street, the Czechs have got plans to gas German villages. I mean, just mad, lurid stories. Loads of stuff about how Czechoslovakia is actually full of Bolsheviks. It's a Trojan horse for the Comintern. The whole stuff is actually very reminiscent of Vladimir Putin about Ukraine. Ukraine full of Nazis, all that kind of stuff. Are there people in Britain and France who worry about this, who think we'd rather Hitler
人们在乎吗？当你日复一日地把这些塞进他们的脑海时，他们就会在乎。当报纸头版写着苏台德德国人遭到袭击、遭到殴打、捷克人要在街上用车碾压他们、捷克人有计划用毒气毒害德国村庄。我的意思是，全都是疯狂、耸人听闻的故事。还有大量关于捷克斯洛伐克其实到处都是布尔什维克的言论。它是共产国际的特洛伊木马。整套说辞实际上非常让人想起弗拉基米尔·普京对乌克兰的论调。乌克兰到处都是纳粹，诸如此类。英国和法国有没有人担心这一点，他们认为比起斯大林，我们宁愿希特勒
had it than Stalin, Czechoslovakia? No, I don't think so. Nobody thinks quite in those terms. I don't think they think, because I don't think they think that Stalin is seriously going to have Czechoslovakia. They know that Czechoslovakia is a democracy and very robust democracy. So the Nazis are pumping out all these stories, but here's the answer to your question. People are shocked at the stories. They feel sorry for the state and Germans, but they don't really care that much.
拥有捷克斯洛伐克？不，我不这么认为。没有人会从那种角度去想。我不认为他们觉得斯大林会认真地占有捷克斯洛伐克。他们知道捷克斯洛伐克是一个民主国家，而且是一个非常稳健的民主国家。所以纳粹在疯狂炮制所有这些故事，但这就是你那个问题的答案。人们对这些故事感到震惊。他们为苏台德德国人感到惋惜，但他们其实并没有那么在乎。
One of the best sources for Germany in this period is a guy called William Shira, who was a radio reporter. The American journalist. American, who wrote a diary. And he said, I don't think Hitler will get his war because people are against it. People don't want it. They say, oh, they feel sorry for the Sudatians, but they, you know, they don't want to fight a war about it. The SPD agents who are reporting to their exiled leadership, they say, actually, people
关于这一时期的德国，最好的消息来源之一是一个叫威廉·夏伊勒的家伙，他是一名电台记者。美国记者。美国人，他写了一篇日记。他说，我不认为希特勒会发动战争，因为人们反对战争。人们不想要战争。他们说，哦，他们为苏台德人感到难过，但他们，你知道，他们不想为此打仗。那些向流亡领导层汇报情况的社会民主党（SPD）特工说，实际上，人们
feel a bit sorry for the Sudatian Germans, but they're much more worried that a war will come about and then there won't be so much food and then it'll be really miserable and they won't, you know, the economic miracle will come to an end and all of this. And Goebbels is actually really annoyed about all this. He's aware of it. He talks about the German people having a war psychosis. He's a bit like George C. Wallace's running mate, Curtis LeMay, saying that people had a phobia of nuclear weapons. They need to man up. Yeah. Get a backbone. People have this mad phobia about a world war. Why?
对苏台德德国人感到有点难过，但他们更担心战争会爆发，然后就没有那么多食物了，接着生活就会变得非常悲惨，而且他们不，你知道，经济奇迹会走向终结，诸如此类。而戈培尔实际上对此感到非常恼火。他意识到了这一点。他谈到德国人民患有战争精神病。他有点像乔治·C·华莱士的竞选搭档柯蒂斯·勒迈，说人们对核武器有恐惧症。他们需要振作起来。是的。拿出骨气来。人们对世界大战有一种疯狂的恐惧症。为什么？
What's not to like? Right. Exactly. So we get to late August. The propaganda machine has been running and running and running. And because of that, the stories have now filtered through to newspapers in London and in Paris as well. And so by the middle of August, 1938, London is full of rumors. What is Hitler going to attack Czechoslovakia? What's going on here? So now we come to Britain. And obviously, our focus in this story is on the Nazis themselves. So we're not going to, you know, we could do thousands of episodes about Britain and appeasement, but we should just do five minutes here. So the prime minister is Neville Chamberlain.
有什么好怕的？对吧。完全如此。所以我们来到了8月下旬。宣传机器一直在开动、开动、开动。正因为如此，这些报道现在已经渗透到了伦敦和巴黎的报纸中。因此，到1938年8月中旬，伦敦到处都是谣言。希特勒要进攻捷克斯洛伐克吗？这到底是怎么回事？所以现在我们转向英国。很显然，我们在故事中的焦点是纳粹本身。所以我们不会，你知道的，我们可以做数千集关于英国和绥靖政策的节目，但我们在这里只需讲五分钟。所以首相是内维尔·张伯伦。
He's been prime minister for a year or so, became prime minister in 1937. I think the thing that people need to get into their heads, this sort of counterintuitive, Neville Chamberlain is not a weedy, dithery, indecisive, cowardly man. That is absolutely not what he is. He is intellectually very formidable. He is very arrogant. He is very inflexible. And he sort of intimidates his cabinet and other politicians because he is the man who knows.
他当了一年左右的首相，于1937年成为首相。我认为人们需要印证的一点是，这种反直觉的看法是：内维尔·张伯伦绝不是一个懦弱、优柔寡断、畏缩不前的懦夫。他绝对不是那样的人。他在智力上非常强大。他非常傲慢。他非常死板。他某种程度上让他的内阁和其他政客感到畏惧，因为他是那个运筹帷幄的人。
He's kind of vulppine, isn't he? And he is a bit chilly. He is. There's a brilliant portrait of him actually in Robert Harris's book on Munich, Robert Harris's novel, where he really captures that sort of sense of Chamberlain's, his pride, his vanity, that he will never change his mind, all of this kind of thing. He really, he always, he will never change his mind, all of this kind of thing. He really, he's always thinks he's, he knows best. He's not this sort of foppish wimp, which is the way he's commonly portrayed.
他有点像狐狸一样狡猾，对吧？而且他有点冷漠。他是的。罗伯特·哈里斯关于慕尼黑的书、罗伯特·哈里斯的小说里其实对他有一个精彩的肖像描写，里面真正捕捉到了张伯伦的那种傲慢、虚荣，他永远不会改变自己的想法，所有诸如此类的事情。他真的，他总是，他永远不会改变自己的想法，所有诸如此类的事情。他真的，他总是觉得自己最懂。他可不是那种花花公子的懦夫，而这正是他通常被描绘的形象。
But you get that sense, don't you? Partly because he seems compared to say the Nazis, an old fashioned figure. So his wing collar, his umbrella, which kind of becomes his emblem. The fact he's only once in his life been up in an airplane, whereas Hitler spent the whole time winging his way around Germany in airplanes. And there is a feeling. So I was kind of, I was just looking up on this cause I read a great book about Chamberlain years ago. So I just looked it up and there was this comment from Ernst von Weizsäcker, who was a diplomat, who's part of that plot, isn't he? Part of the general's plot and actually father of the,
但你确实会有那种感觉，不是吗？部分原因在于，与纳粹相比，他似乎是一个过时的老派人物。所以他的立领衬衫、他的雨伞——这几乎成了他的标志。他一生中只坐过一次飞机，而希特勒则把全部时间都花在乘飞机周游德国上。而且确实有一种感觉。所以我就，我当时只是在查阅这个，因为我几年前读过一本关于张伯伦的好书。所以我查了一下，埃恩斯特·冯·魏茨泽克（Ernst von Weizsäcker）——他是一名外交官，也是那个阴谋的一部分，不是吗？将军阴谋的一部分，实际上还是那个魏茨泽克的父亲，
the Weizsäcker who then became president of Germany, I think in the nineties. And he wrote, if Chamberlain comes, these louts, by which he means the Nazis will triumph and proclaim that some Englishman has taken his cue and come to heel. They, the English should send an energetic military man who if necessary can shout and hit the table with a riding crop, a marshal with many decorations and scars, a man without too much consideration. The guy he wanted was a general literally called General Ironside. He thought this was the guy who should go. So I think there is a sense that Chamberlain's image is a problem, that he does seem fusty and Edwardian compared
那个在九十年代成为德国总统的魏茨泽克。他写道：“如果张伯伦来，这些粗人——他指的是纳粹——将会胜利，并宣称某个英国人已经顺从并乖乖就范了。他们，英国人应该派一个精力充沛的军人，必要时可以大喊大叫并用马鞭敲打桌子，一个佩戴着许多勋章和伤疤的元帅，一个不太讲究的人。”他想要的那个人是一个名叫艾恩赛德（Ironside）的将军。他认为这才是应该去的人。所以我认为人们确实觉得张伯伦的形象是个问题，与那些雷厉风行的法西斯分子相比，他显得迂腐而又带有爱德华时代的气息。
to the go ahead kind of fascist. Well, here's the weird thing with Chamberlain. Chamberlain in his own mind is a very modern politician. So although he dresses in an old fashioned way, he thinks I am modernity because he, but he, here's the thing. He thinks they are old fashioned. He thinks all that stuff about wearing a military uniform, wars, he thinks that's like Winston Churchill. That's like 1890s. Because he's all about municipal drains and...
好吧，关于张伯伦，奇怪的地方在于：张伯伦在自己的心目中是一个非常现代的政治家。所以尽管他穿着老派，但他认为我代表着现代性，因为他——但是，关键在这里。他认为他们才是老派的。他认为所有那些穿军服、打仗的事情，他认为那是温斯顿·丘吉尔那一套。那是18世纪90年代的风格。因为他关心的全是市政下水道和……
Yes, that's the future. Health service. He was a brilliant minister for health in the 1920s. Because he's the product of the kind of the civic government of Birmingham, isn't he? Absolutely. So Neville Chamberlain in his own mind is the future and Hitler and co are the past. They're mad relics of the Great War. But of course, you're absolutely right.
是的，那是未来。卫生服务部门。他在20世纪20年代是一位杰出的卫生大臣。因为他是伯明翰市民政府的产物，对吧？绝对是的。所以内维尔·张伯伦在自己心目中代表着未来，而希特勒等人则是过去。他们是第一次世界大战的疯狂残余。但当然，你是绝对正确的。
To them, he looks like this effeminate, foppish, effete, absolute wimp and weed who is backwards. You're dead right about that. But I think Chamberlain does embody British public opinion in the late 1930s. All the commentary in Britain about war at this point is that war would be unbelievably apocalyptic. That our cities would be levelled by bombers. The bomber always gets through.
在他们眼里，他看起来像个娘娘腔、浮夸、娇惯、绝对的懦夫，是个落伍的人。你这话完全说对了。但我认为张伯伦确实体现了20世纪30年代末的英国公众舆论。当时英国所有关于战争的评论都认为，战争将是难以想象的毁灭性的。我们的城市将被轰炸机夷为平地。轰炸机总是能突破防线。
The bomber always gets through. Stanley Baldwin quote. The whole business about gas masks, you know, all the famous pictures of little children clutching their gas masks and they're being evacuated. We will be attacked with gas. Of course, we know now that didn't happen, but people think at the time everybody will be gassed if a war happens. There will be millions and millions of casualties. And so this is the heyday of peace petitions, peace ballots, the Labour Party is the party of disarmament. The Oxford union saying that they wouldn't fight for king and country.
轰炸机总是能突破防线。斯坦利·鲍德温的名言。关于防毒面具的整套事情，你知道，所有那些小孩子紧紧抓着防毒面具并被疏散的著名照片。我们将遭到毒气攻击。当然，我们现在知道那并没有发生，但当时的人们认为，如果战争爆发，所有的人都会遭到毒气袭击。将会有数以百万计的伤亡。所以这是和平请愿书、和平投票的鼎盛时期，工党是主张裁军的政党。牛津辩论社说他们不会为国王和国家而战。
Wouldn't fight for king and country, all of this. And of course, Chablan knows all this. He also knows most people in Britain could not give a hoot about central Europe. So Richard Evans in his book on the Nazis at war makes this point and he's absolutely right. Most people in Britain, they do care about India, Australia, South Africa, because those are the stories that are in their newspapers every day. Even then, they don't really care about that much. Of course. I mean, they might care about Australia if they're playing cricket, but otherwise,
不会为国王和国家而战，诸如此类。当然，张伯伦深知这一切。他也知道英国的大多数人根本不在乎中欧。所以理查德·埃文斯在他的《战争中的纳粹》一书中提出了这一点，他是完全正确的。英国的大多数人，他们确实在乎印度、澳大利亚、南非，因为那是每天出现在他们报纸上的故事。即便如此，他们其实也没有那么在乎。当然。我的意思是，如果他们在板球比赛中可能会在乎澳大利亚，否则的话，
I mean, they don't really care about the empire very much. The lesson of history, nobody ever cares about anybody else, let's be honest. But they definitely don't care about the empire very much. The lesson of history, nobody ever cares about anybody else, let's be honest. But they definitely don't care about Czechoslovakia where they've never been, they don't know where it is. They don't understand what it is, as we will see from Neville Chamberlain's quote. A far away country of which we know little. Yeah.
我的意思是，他们其实并不怎么在乎帝国。历史的教训是，老实说，从来没有人真正在乎过别人。但他们绝对不怎么在乎捷克斯洛伐克，他们从来没去过那里，甚至不知道它在哪里。正如我们将从内维尔·张伯伦的名言中所看到的，他们根本不明白那是什么。“一个我们知之甚少的遥远国家。”是的。
So Chamberlain, the other big problem I think Chamberlain has, Chamberlain is a smart guy. He's a very rational person. He's very controlled. And I think as a result of all that, he is imaginatively limited. So he cannot conceive of the kind of person Hitler is. He's never met anyone like Hitler. The idea that this person could be seething with racial animosity
所以张伯伦，我认为张伯伦面临的另一个大问题是，张伯伦是个聪明人。他是一个非常理性的人。他非常克制。我认为正因为这一切，他的想象力受到了限制。所以他根本无法想象希特勒到底是怎样的人。他从未见过像希特勒这样的人。这个人竟然会被种族敌意所吞噬，
and could be driven by this apocalyptic worldview. You know, there's nobody like that in the house of comments. Yeah. Chamberlain, there's no one like that in Birmingham, Tom. No. He's never met anyone like that. So when he looks at this, he says, well, it seems to me perfectly rational that we could solve this Sudeten problem and everybody, you know, we could all be friends.
并被这种世界末日般的世界观所驱使。你知道，下议院里可没有这样的人。是的，张伯伦，伯明翰可没有这样的人，汤姆。没有。他从未见过这样的人。所以当他看到这一情况时，他说，好吧，在我看来，我们完全可以理智地解决这个苏台德问题，每个人，你知道的，我们都可以成为朋友。
Which is obviously, that's the great flaw in Chamberlain's vision, as we shall see. So anyway, let's move towards the end of the episode. On the 30th of August, as a result of all this, Chamberlain's cabinet agree they will not issue a warning to deter Hitler from attacking Czechoslovakia. Why not? Because they think it would inflame him and it would provoke things. They want to have a peaceful settlement. So what they'll do is they will talk to the Czechoslovak president, who's
很显然，这正是张伯伦愿景中的巨大缺陷，正如我们将看到的。所以无论如何，让我们走向这一集的尾声。8月30日，由于这一切，张伯伦的内阁达成一致，他们不会发出警告来阻止希特勒进攻捷克斯洛伐克。为什么不呢？因为他们认为这会激怒他并挑起事端。他们希望达成和平解决。所以他们要做的就是与捷克斯洛伐克总统交谈，也就是
a guy called Edvard Benes, and they will get him to give concessions to the Sudeten Germans. Now Benes, he is a former lecturer in sociology and people who enjoy scouting be pleased to hear that like Harold Wilson, he was a massive enthusiast for the boy scout movement, which I think reflects well on him. Do you know what? He was also a Freemason like Shaquille O'Neal. So if you have an image in your mind of a sociology lecture, who's a fusion of
一个叫爱德华·贝奈斯（Edvard Benes）的家伙，他们会让他向苏台德德国人作出妥协。贝奈斯曾是一名社会学讲师，喜欢童子军的人听到这里会很高兴，和哈罗德·维尔逊一样，他曾是童子军运动的超级狂热爱好者，我认为这对他是个好评价。你知道吗？他还是个共济会成员，就像沙奎尔·奥尼尔一样。所以如果你脑海中有一个社会学讲师的形象，他简直就是
Shaquille O'Neal and Harold Wilson. Goodness. There's something. Yeah. I mean, you wouldn't, you wouldn't have thought that a sociology lecturer was the kind of person who would basically be suited to standing up to Hitler. No, I would be right. Benesch, I mean, he's pretty tough.
沙奎尔·奥尼尔和哈罗德·维尔逊的结合体。天哪。这可真有意思。是的。我的意思是，你不会认为一个社会学讲师会是那种基本上适合挺身而出对抗希特勒的人。不，我这么想就对了。贝奈斯，我的意思是，他相当强硬。
Yeah. Well, Hitler, I mean, kind of ends up saying, well, he's a lot tougher than the Austrians were. Yes, well, he is. There's no doubt about that. The Czechoslovakia are much tougher than the Austrians. So Benesch says, okay, fine. You know. We'll give the Sudeten Germans what they want. We'll give them some more autonomy. We'll move to a more federal system in Czechoslovakia. Czechoslovakia already has other tensions between the Czechs and Slovaks, for example. He says, we'll have a more
嗯，希特勒，我的意思是，最后说，嗯，他比奥地利人顽强得多。是的，没错，他确实如此。毫无疑问。捷克斯洛伐克人比奥地利人强硬得多。所以贝奈斯说，好吧，没问题。你知道的。我们会给苏台德德国人他们想要的东西。我们会给他们更多的自治权。我们将在捷克斯洛伐克推行更联邦制的系统。捷克斯洛伐克内部已经存在其他矛盾，例如捷克人和斯洛伐克人之间。他说，我们将建立一个更
federal system. Fine. Of course, that's not what Hitler wants. Hitler doesn't want concessions. He wants a pretext for a full invasion. So basically he says to the Sudeten Germans, just reject that offer. Say that you can't trust Spanish, which they do. They say, oh, well, we don't, we can't, nothing you offer us will be good enough because we don't believe a word you say. So another week goes by and it's full of claims from the Sudeten Germans. Oh, we're being attacked.
联邦制。很好。当然，希特勒想要的不是这个。希特勒不想要妥协。他想要一个全面入侵的借口。所以基本上他对苏台德地区的德国人说，直接拒绝那个提案。说你们不能信任捷克人，他们也照做了。他们说，哦，好吧，我们不，我们不能，你们提出的任何条件都不够好，因为我们连你们说的一个字都不信。于是又过了一个星期，充满了来自苏台德德国人的指控。哦，我们正在遭受袭击。
We're being abused, all of this kind of thing. And then on the 11th of September, 1938, there was a dramatic new development. Across Western Czechoslovakia, the Sudeten Germans, Henlein supporters, stage big demonstrations and they incite clashes with the Czech police. Of course, this was done on orders from Berlin. And this was the context for the speech that you began with, Hitler's great rant at the party congress in Nuremberg, where he says, they're being ravaged, they're being tortured, all of this kind of thing.
我们正在被虐待，诸如此类的事情。接着在1938年9月11日，出现了一个戏剧性的新进展。在捷克斯洛伐克西部，苏台德德国人、海因lein的支持者举行了大型游行示威，并煽动与捷克警察的冲突。当然，这是奉柏林的命令进行的。这就是你开头提到的那场演讲的背景，希特勒在纽伦堡党代会上发表的慷慨激昂的演说，他在那里声称，他们正在被蹂躏，他们正在被折磨，所有这些诸如此类的话。
And he has planned this out meticulously. This is the starting gun. This is going to be the great launch for the campaign. So in three weeks time, we'll go in. And in that speech that you did, he lays out his case very carefully. He says, Czechoslovakia is a made up country created by the United Nations.
而且他对此进行了精心策划。这是发令枪。这将是这场战役的宏大序幕。所以在三周时间内，我们将长驱直入。在你提到的那场演讲中，他非常仔细地陈述了自己的理由。他说，捷克斯洛伐克是一个由联合国制造出来的拼凑国家。
He says, and I quote, the Sudeten Germans are being ravaged and raped. I have begged and begged the democracies for redress, but they have ignored me. And finally, Germany is gonna, we're gonna have to stand up for our kith and kin. So this is very Vladimir Putin speech, 2022 before going into Ukraine. Same day he gives that speech, there was a new outbreak of violence across Czechoslovakia's
他说，我引述一下，“苏台德地区的德国人正在遭受蹂躏和强奸。我一再恳求民主国家主持公道，但他们却置之不理。”最终，德国不得不站出来支持我们的同胞。所以这是一场非常像弗拉基米尔·普京在2022年进攻乌克兰之前的演讲。就在他发表那场演讲的同一天，捷克斯洛伐克西部边境地区再次爆发了暴力冲突。
western borderlands. There are bomb scares, there are attacks on post offices and railway stations and so on. And then the next day, the 13th of September, a lot of fighting breaks out in a place called Habersbeek, this village, the Czech police are sent in and four of them are killed by Henlein's goons, by his thugs. And the Czechs then declare martial law and they send troops into the streets. So this is brilliant. This is just what Hitler wants. All going to plan.
那里有炸弹恐吓，有针对邮局和火车站的袭击等等。然后在第二天，即9月13日，在一个叫哈伯斯贝克的地方爆发了激烈的战斗，在这个村庄里，捷克警察被派了过去，其中四人被海因lein的爪牙、他的暴徒杀害。随后捷克人宣布进入戒严状态，并派遣军队走上街头。所以这太妙了。这正是希特勒想要的。一切都在按计划进行。
Exactly. What could possibly go wrong? Well, then Tom, there is a twist. There are going to be so many twists in these episodes. This is the first of a series of massive twists. Because Neville Chamberlain, meanwhile, has been off grouse shooting while all this is going on. Of course he has.
完全正确。能出什么岔子呢？好吧，汤姆，事情出现了转折。这些剧集里会有数不清的转折。这是这一系列巨大转折中的第一个。因为与此同时，内维尔·张伯伦在这一切发生的时候一直在外出打松鸡。他当然去了。
But I guess while he's been out there in the, you know, in the heather, he's been, you know, working out what could we do. His mighty mind. His mighty, his vulpine, cool, chill, calculating brain has been at work. It has. Now Chamberlain has already decided the Sudetenland should be given to Germany. He just thinks it's mad to fight for the Sudetenland, it's full of Germans.
但我猜当他在荒野中，你知道的，在石楠丛中时，他一直在，你知道的，琢磨我们能做些什么。他那伟大的头脑。他那强大的、狡猾的、冷静的、沉着计算的大脑一直在运转。确实如此。现在张伯伦已经决定应该把苏台德地区让给德国。他只是觉得为苏台德地区开战太疯狂了，那里到处都是德国人。
Like the Czechs should just let it go. He knows the British people don't want war. His military chiefs have already told him, they told him on the 13th of September, if there is a war Czechoslovakia would fall in weeks and we anticipate the Luftwaffe would bomb our cities every day for two months. You know, an incredibly kind of bleak, miserable prognosis. Chamberlain is horrified by this because he hates war, but he also thinks, you know, I'm the man, I can fix this. And he comes up with something that he calls Plan Z. And he thinks, I can carry out a diplomatic coup that will change the entire picture.
就像捷克人应该放手一样。他知道英国人民不希望战争。他的军事参谋已经在9月13日告诉过他，他们说如果发生战争，捷克斯洛伐克几周内就会沦陷，而且我们预计德国空军每天都会轰炸我们的城市长达两个月。你知道，这是一种极其凄凉、悲惨的预测。张伯伦对此感到惊恐，因为他讨厌战争，但他也觉得，你知道的，我是那个人，我能解决这个问题。于是他想出了一个他称之为“Z计划”的东西。他认为，我可以实施一场将改变整个局面的外交政变。
And he's always writing these letters to his sisters and he writes letters to his sister and he says, I will wait. I will bide my time. I will wait until things look blackest and then I will astonish the world. He's very vain man, Chamberlain. So on the night of the 13th of September, he decides the time has come and he sends this message to Berlin in view of the increasingly critical situation, he says, I am prepared to rip up diplomatic protocol. I will fly personally to Germany to meet Hitler and to find a peaceful solution. I could come tomorrow if you like. I'm ready. This is an amazing thing.
他总是给他的姐妹们写信，他给他的姐姐写信说，我会等待。我会养精蓄锐。我会等到局势最黑暗的时候，然后我要让世界大吃一惊。张伯伦是个非常虚荣的人。所以在9月13日夜里，他决定时机已到，他向柏林发出了这条信息：鉴于日益严峻的局势，他说，我准备打破外交礼节。我将亲自飞往德国会见希特勒，以寻求和平解决方案。如果你愿意，我明天就可以去。我已经准备好了。这是一件了不起的事。
Because no summit like this has ever happened before. Exactly. Think about the series we did about the buildup to the Great War, where it's all telegrams and you know, no one would ever interact their holiday to do anything. And it's kind of again looking, I guess, kind of it's looking forward to the summits that will be held between the Americans and the Soviets. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. I mean, this is a sign again of Chamberlain's modernity, right? That he's happy to do this. So half a day goes by and the world is waiting. And then on the early afternoon of the 14th of September, the
因为从来没有发生过这样的峰会。没错。想想我们制作的关于第一次世界大战前夕的那系列节目，那里全都是电报，而且你知道的，没有人会为了做任何事而打断他们的假期。这某种程度上又让人联想到，我猜，某种程度上这是在展望未来美国人和苏联人之间将要举行的峰会。对，没错，没错。我的意思是，这也是张伯伦现代性的一种表现，对吧？他很乐意这么做。于是半天过去了，全世界都在等待。然后在9月14日午后不久，柏林的
reply comes from Berlin and Hitler says, I would be delighted to see you at the eagle's nest tomorrow. And so at eight o'clock in the morning of the 15th of September, 1938, Neville Chamberlain boards his plane at Heston aerodrome for one of the most controversial flights in history. Well, Dominic, you said that this is a story full of twists and cliffhangers, and this is definitely a cliffhanger. So if you want to find out what happens next, how will Chamberlain get on with Hitler? Will there be peace in our time? You can hear the episode, the next episode right away. And if you are not a member of the Restless History
回复传来了，希特勒说，我很高兴明天能在鹰巢接待您。于是，在1938年9月15日早上八点，内维尔·张伯伦在赫斯顿机场登上飞机，踏上了历史中最具争议的飞行之一。好吧，多米尼克，你说过这是一个充满转折和悬念的故事，这绝对是一个悬念。所以如果你想知道接下来会发生什么，张伯伦将如何与希特勒相处？我们的时代会有和平吗？你可以立刻收听这一集，下一集节目。如果你还不是“其余历史”俱乐部的会员，
Club, you can join and get it at therestlesshistory.com. But if you'd rather wait, we will be back on Thursday with the story of Chamberlain's three flights to Germany, the Munich conference and, well, I'm giving it away here. The fall of Czechoslovakia. Goodbye. As promised, here's a clip from the Rest is Politics US mini-series. Trump is naturally a conspiracy theorist fueler. He will fuel the fire of any conspiracy theory because he's always seen himself as an outsider and he wants to foment the people from the outside to attack the people from the inside. So he's developing these ideas that he eventually uses in january on the sixth of january and the ideas are there's misinformation out there. as fodder to attack the people on the inside. He's doing it with COVID.
你可以加入并在 therestlesshistory.com 获取它。但如果你宁愿等待，我们将在周四回归，带来张伯伦三次飞往德国、慕尼黑会议的故事，以及，好吧，我在这里剧透了。捷克斯洛伐克的沦陷。再见。正如承诺的那样，以下是“政治的其余部分：美国”迷你剧的片段。特朗普天生就是一个阴谋论的煽动者。他会为任何阴谋论火上浇油，因为他一直把自己视为一个局外人，他想要煽动局外的人去攻击局内的人。所以他正在形成这些想法，并最终在1月6日运用了这些想法，这些想法就是：外面存在着错误信息。作为攻击局内人的草料。他在对新冠疫情这样做。
I think hydroxychloroquine works. You may remember this. I took hydroxychloroquine. Mr. President, you took hydroxychloroquine? Yeah, yeah, I'm on it. I took it. And this is the beginning. This is the kernels of what's about to come.
我认为羟氯喹有效。你可能还记得这个。我服用过羟氯喹。总统先生，您服用过羟氯喹？对，对，我在用。我服用了。这就是这一切的开始。这就是即将发生之事的萌芽。
And it all starts with COVID, and it leads up to this insurrection, or as the president says, a very peaceful group of tourists descending upon the Capitol building. If you want to hear the rest of the show, go and search The Rest Is Politics US, wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一切都始于新冠疫情，并导致了这场叛乱，或者正如总统所说，是一群非常和平的游客涌入国会大厦。如果你想收听节目的其余部分，请在获取播客的任何地方搜索“The Rest Is Politics US”。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。